Ah,
the Joe Rogan experience podcast is brought to you by the fleshlight.
If you go to Joe rogan.net and click on the link for the flashlight and entering
the code name,
Rogan,
you will get 15% off the number one sex toy for men.
A sex toy that Duncan Trussell my guest has put his penis into.
Yeah,
but you did a dude only like only 15 times.
Only 50 times.
Didn't you get tossed out and not by you that,
oh yeah,
that's happened.
I've got weird.
A lot of weird fleshlight stories I know.
And his life.
Women resent having that around.
Yeah,
don't they?
A lot of them,
not all of them,
but there's a few women who look at that as almost like a minor league woman.
Well,
they get,
yeah,
they get definitely get ties to,
I mean also there,
the problem is this gross to them.
It's,
I think it's also a little embarrassing because it's like you don't want someone
to open up your asshole.
And I can,
when they come over like,
Hey,
what's this?
What's this?
It can't,
oh,
there's an ass hole.
So large fosters
good hosts,
opens it up and it's just
fucking,
the Jays pubes are on it.
His pubes
so embarrassing if you went,
came into your husband's a office and use flashlights.
Yeah,
exactly.
What you got to hide.
I'm like,
yeah,
you got to hide them.
You can't leave him out in the open.
No one,
no one.
Everyone knows that's not [inaudible]
fosters cam.
But they work so good.
It's so much better than beating off.
You know?
And if everybody,
it's,
it's a weird thing to get behind because if everybody beats off,
why,
why is it so embarrassing to,
to have like technology that aids your beat?
Was that embarrassing?
Can I tell you my theory about how applied it's better than beating off cause I
think that,
uh,
over the course of evolution,
I think if if first beating off trick your body and to thinking you'd fucked,
like you beat off your body got the same satisfied feeling you get when you
fucked right.
And then body started figuring out,
oh wait a minute is trick me or not really reproducing.
And so then it makes it so when you jerk off,
it feels great,
but it doesn't feel as good as fucking,
it's not the same.
You don't get that same feeling of like,
I just had sex.
Well you also,
you know,
I do a whole bit about it.
How you can feel your hand.
Yeah.
It's a problem.
You can't
really hard to trick yourself,
but the fleshlight I think it tricks your body actually the animal part of your
body and your body thinks he fucked because you,
yeah,
you should
loads.
Yeah.
You don't shoot the kind of,
you don't shoot the pinstripe floats.
Beat off.
Loads are not as satisfying though.
You know,
you get a beat off low and you're like,
that's it.
That's all I have in me.
That's it.
That's all I was able to muster up.
Well,
it's funny when you're coming inside a flashlight and guys,
I'm sorry to get dirty,
but when you're coming inside a flashlight and you're,
you're,
you're pushing forward into the fleshlight and spraying Jay's into it,
your body thinks it's getting something pregnant.
Your body really thinks it does.
Yeah.
It's kind sad and it really
thinks it's getting a good specimen because it's tight and to see like,
oh,
this is good genes here.
Yeah,
this is a good vagina.
The one you get,
the last one you gave me.
I mean,
I,
I don't want to be a bad one.
Well,
I mean with all due respect,
it looks like Frankenstein.
It's Halloween
themed one.
It's a vagina that's got stitches.
What appears or no?
Yeah.
Oh,
anyway,
you got to Joe rogan.net and click does a longest fleshlight commercial ever.
Go to Joe rogan.net.
Click on the link and enter in the code name Brogan and you get 15% off and
yeah,
it's silly.
Yeah,
it's a silly thing.
But if you like beating off,
this is better and everybody likes beating off,
so go buy some [inaudible] were also brought to you by onnit.com uh,
makers of Alpha brain,
uh,
which is,
a point of contention on the Internet.
There's a lot of people,
uh,
who,
don't like the idea behind it.
A lot of people say there's not enough science behind it.
Yeah,
I see a lot of your points.
I really do.
However,
people have been taking these,
these,
these plant compounds,
they've been taking these,
you know,
these different extracts from,
from plants for a long time.
I mean for,
there's like a recorded use of like velvet bean of,
of thousands of years.
People have been using it.
I don't know if it can have adverse effect on anything cause I'm not a fucking
scientist,
but I've looked at it and it's,
it's worth it to me to take a chance.
I've,
I've looked at the data and I know how to use some of the things like Coleen on
Alzheimer's patients and man,
when I take it,
I,
I feel good.
It gives me a nice little,
a little bump or something.
And you know,
a lot of people say doesn't do shit for them.
And other people have even said that it makes,
it makes them sick.
Like it makes them feel nauseous.
So I guess,
you know the human body and look,
everybody's not the same.
Some people can't drink coffee.
I fucking love coffee.
You know,
some people can't have milk,
they'll lactose intolerant.
I mean,
I don't know what,
what,
you know,
it's,
if,
if something has an effect on you,
you know,
like this Alpha brain stuff does.
It's got a not jive with everybody.
It's just that's the way it is.
There's no other way around it,
in my opinion.
Probably,
you know,
I,
I don't know what,
what each person's individual sensitivities are.
Yeah.
But I do know that for a lot of people it does a lot of good.
You know,
what's weird man?
It's like what you're just saying,
like,
you know,
it,
it probably interfaces with people's bodies differently in some of them might
feel some nausea.
Yeah.
Pharmaceutical companies,
when they release products,
they know,
oh yeah,
there's going to be like 600 people who get seriously fucked up from this shit
because that's why they have to run that stuff.
And the commercials and the pharmaceutical commercials,
you know,
they say may cause death or serious homicidal thoughts,
suicidal thoughts.
Can you imagine a releasing something like that into the world and knowing,
no.
Yeah.
This is going to kill some people.
Some people.
Yeah,
that's an interesting point because it's like not everything is,
no one is exactly like someone else.
Like as far as like how their body processes things.
We all know people who literally can't drink alcohol for whatever reason.
Their body just doesn't process it.
Right.
And they go fucking off the wires.
Yeah.
Right.
Yup.
And then we know you or I,
who can,
you know,
have a couple beers.
I've seen you drunk,
you're just Dunkin drunk,
you know,
you're you when you're drunk,
drunk and trust yet drug.
He trusts me.
Well how about the thing he did for me,
we've talked about this before,
but just if you haven't seen it,
you got to go online and watch drunk history.
Dunkin does this drunk history with Nikola Tesla and it's fucking brilliant.
They get him hammered where he's throwing up in a toilet and he's talking about
the history of one of my personal heroes.
You know,
one of my shell,
I don't want to say heroes,
but one of the people that's been a fixture of my life,
one of my people,
the men that lived at a most fascinated by is that Nikola Tesla.
So it's a fucking awesome thing.
We've talked about it before,
but go see it.
If you haven't seen it,
go look it up on Youtube.
It's a fucking awesome,
you know?
Um,
but yeah,
everybody's bodies fucking different,
man.
You know,
some people,
some people can't smoke weed,
some people love it.
David tell doesn't like it.
Doug.
Stan hope doesn't like it.
Right.
You know?
Yeah.
And this is brilliant people,
you know,
I don't ever love and respect him and my,
everybody's body is different man.
People,
some people can't eat fucking walnuts.
You know,
I have a friend of candied walnuts when it doesn't.
Brian Keaulana of a Brazil nut fucking thing.
He's got zilch.
You know,
sloppy kitchens are,
you get one little nice salad.
By mistake.
I mean condoms in there.
Yeah.
I think Brian Callan is allergic to Brazil nuts.
I'm pretty sure it's set it,
I think it was him.
I don't want to,
I'll have to ask,
but you know,
it's just some wacky shit man.
It's not,
it doesn't,
everybody's body is not the same.
But all this stuff in Alpha brain I think is relatively innocuous.
And I think it,
if you don't like the effects of it,
you can get off of it.
It's real simple.
If it,
it might not work for you.
And if you,
if,
and then I always say this and people say you don't really mean this,
I fucking do mean this.
What I'm about to say,
if you worry at all about how much across,
don't buy it.
Just go look into nootropics,
try a bunch of the other shit.
What's that called?
Stuff called Parasso.
Tim,
that's a really interesting one.
There's,
there's a bunch of,
there's a focus factor that they have their own compounds they put together and
there's a bunch of other ones.
Man,
there's some interesting stuff.
It's interesting.
If I had nothing to do with this financially,
I would still tell you to try it out because it's fascinating and I've always
endorsed nootropics,
I think.
I think there's some science behind it.
I think there's,
there's a,
there's not enough to like firmly state exactly what each one does.
Unequivocably you know,
this is how you can measure it.
This is the exact dose.
It's not like,
you know,
I don't think it's that clean yet.
It's,
it's,
there's,
there's just a lot of anecdotal evidence that this stuff does.
Something to enhance the way your works.
Not,
not crazy.
It's not limitless.
It's not,
it's not a fucking magic pill.
It doesn't make retards intelligent.
It's,
it's just a little better.
I'm trying to not say retarded anymore.
Oh yeah.
You're cutting that word out of your vagina,
Larry,
just to,
just to shut people up,
man.
It's a,
it's a great word,
but you know,
automatically it becomes babies with down syndrome.
Right.
It becomes the worst possible definition for it.
You know,
you don't mean it like that though.
It's clean your time.
No,
I don't.
Anyway,
if you go to a,
what does the music plan a go to on a.com and enter in the code name Brogan Tri
Alpha brain.
And what I was saying is if you don't,
if this is what I,
what I was saying,
that seems like,
I don't really mean,
but I really do mean if you think it costs too much,
go by the,
the quantities of the ingredients or whatever the fuck is in Alpha brain is we
show it online,
just copy it,
copy it,
go buy the shit and try it out yourself or try one or two of them out yourself.
Some of them you're not going to like,
and some of them you might like,
I think,
you know,
it's,
it's a very interesting sort of a pursuit,
the pursuit of enhancing mental function through nutrients.
But I'm a big believer in vitamins and minerals.
I think it's,
it's enhanced my body and I'm very much in tune with my body because I eat well
and I exercise.
And I think it's very important that you know,
you do that,
you've got to take care of the fucking machine that carries you around.
So for me,
I'm pretty tuned in to what my body feels like an irregular basis.
And because of that,
I can,
I can get a good feel of when something's helping me for real or something's a
placebo effect,
you know,
it's,
um,
it's a real fine line,
you know,
because quite honestly,
man,
placebo is a powerful,
powerful effect and we don't really understand.
I,
I wouldn't mind really placebos all day if they just rocked my world.
You know?
I mean,
when you think about what the human body is really capable of,
and I'm not endorsing lying to people,
but I'm saying,
I mean,
think about what the effect of Placebo is.
A,
for a lot of people,
it's really fucking dramatic,
man.
They act as if they've gotten medicine.
You know,
cancer has been a,
and I,
I,
it's ever been cured,
but it's,
tumors have shrunk,
you know?
Uh,
is that true?
Look that up.
Looked at it shrunk.
You sure?
Yeah.
I'm,
I'm not 100% sure I heard that.
That's a good thing to look at.
But I know that it's,
I know that there have been some substantial medical improvements because of the
placebo effect,
and it's a fascinating effect.
I wish someone could just placebo me all day.
I wish you could just convince me that I could go to some lady and she wipes me
with a chicken's foot and you know,
and your,
your liver liver heals up.
You know,
I wish I,
you know,
I wish it was possible to just trigger placebos left and right.
Well,
somebody
emailed me.
Something else you could maybe check out Brian,
is that they think that it might be,
there might be,
you know,
there's natural cannabinoids in the brain.
Yeah.
And they think it's somehow associated with that brain just releases these
cannabinoids and it gives you a,
I'm just saying,
ah,
assholes with tumors on him.
Hmm.
I'll take,
I'll take the word.
I'll take
the word butthole hole.
Out of that.
You always did.
He had butthole to every Google search.
It does.
This is a grown man.
Anyway.
If you go to Joe Rogan dot.
And then you click on the link for that.
Oh.
And the other thing is Alpha brain,
if you don't like it,
it's a hundred percent money back guarantee.
Even if you've eaten it.
If you take by,
especially by 30 pills,
the small ones just take it and if you don't like it,
you get your money back.
Even if you eat it and that's the best thing because I mean honestly what you
can't get mad at that you can't get mad.
That's all we can do.
All we can do is be as honest as possible.
Tell you get the 30 cal get the small amount.
If you don't like it,
send it back.
We give you all your money back 100% I can tell you eaten every single pill.
My grandmother
there died and I put Alpha brain into her mouth and she came back to life.
I heard that shit.
I heard that.
Yeah,
it will bring your grandmother back to life,
but they can't be dead for that long.
Like how long?
What do you mean?
How long was she dead for?
Oh,
it wasn't like a week.
No,
it was like three.
It's a couple of days.
She did.
Then we were at his board.
Her corpse had been laying there for a while and I'm like,
fuck it.
Put Alpha for Brandon her mouth.
Anyway,
my,
my uh,
tennis.
Please don't buy off of brain.
If you have any questions,
don't buy it.
Please don't.
Don't,
don't buy it.
I don't want you to buy it.
If you're thinking,
should I buy this shit,
please don't buy it.
Okay?
But look into nootropics.
Just look it up online.
It's a fascinating thing and if you want to buy Alpha brain,
go to [inaudible] dot com work for me.
It gave me weird dreams.
The code name,
Rogan,
and you get 10% off that shit.
Bitch.
Duncan trussell's here.
Let the music begin.
We're in the new desk squad studio experience.
Try my day.
Joe Rogan podcast,
my night all day.
[inaudible]
I had a pink,
somebody on my board yesterday for complaining that I do the commercials before
the podcast.
You know,
he was bitching about it.
Something like these stupid fuck.
Go to the special ed room,
dummy.
It's ridiculous.
I'll give you a free podcast,
man.
I have to,
I have to do something to monetize this bitch,
right?
Yeah.
And Cart bandwidth costs money.
It's really fucking annoying when people give you those like con those types
plane about something.
When I give you something for two and a half hours for free and I'm just talking
about,
you know,
a product for two minutes,
you're getting commercial man,
here's a
comment I just got on a youtube video.
Let me see if I remember.
It was really annoying.
What I,
these are the,
these are the fucking car and salt comments I selling out.
They're the ones that start with a compliment,
but her passive,
the passive aggressive ones.
So this one was,
I like for 20 minutes I took the paranormal activity,
you know how paranormal activity shows,
um,
the crowd and doesn't show the,
so it's the crowd reacting to paranormal activity if you,
you seen that.
So it's like people are like,
oh no.
And I thought,
well fuck man,
that's funny.
I wonder what that would look like if they were reacting to a red lobster
commercial.
So I just put a red lobster commercial on top of them,
like freaking out over a scary movie.
And it came out kind of funny,
weird.
And so I put that up on my youtube page and someone left the comments like,
well,
this is uh,
this is the only one of your videos that didn't make me laugh.
Why would you even fucking say that?
It's like a compliment,
uh,
in very nice complement.
Makes them,
it's just like a Shitty Jab.
He gave me a check minus.
Well,
you know what it is,
is when you get on the Internet,
you are allowing yourself to interact with anybody,
anybody and everybody.
And you're not,
you don't keep,
can't choose it all.
There's no choosing.
Any random person can just cut their way into your life.
Just content store right through your fucking life.
Online.
Yeah.
And it's not like a real commute.
I mean,
you can create a community online with a message board or something like that,
but with Twitter lists and shit like that,
like who you follow,
who you block.
But you know,
at the end of the day,
just,
you know,
it's,
this is the boundaries between people are kind of separated and people can just
get at people.
And so youtube comments are a perfect example of that.
You want to see like how the world is going.
You look at the youtube comments.
If the youtube comments were like,
well better luck next time and he seems like a cool guy.
It wasn't my kind of music,
but I could see how some people get like it.
That's a nice way.
Or each shit drown in a river of AIDS.
You faggot,
cons,
fame.
Yeah.
I mean do you see those over and over again and yeah.
Youtube doesn't block them and it is a fascinating sociological experiment.
Thousands of years from now,
if data's still exists,
if you can still read off of our hard drives,
probably you won't be able to,
but whoever finds us in our archeological future,
the way we have found ancient Sumeria or ancient Rome or you know,
any civilization that we've tried to piece together from information from the
past,
they're going to look at youtube comments and they're going to be like,
look at these crazy ass holes.
Yeah,
look at these motherfuckers.
Any,
any video that they go to.
What if they went to Rebecca Black?
Here's just a 1314 year old girl talking about and hanging out with their
freedoms and she had a song,
she's 14 years old,
man,
she's a little girl.
You're not supposed to like that song if you're a fucking grown person.
But that song was assaulted by a fucking tsunami of Shit.
Yep.
You those comments and you look at like her 25 million hits or whatever the hell
she had.
The comments on her videos are horrendous.
They're terrifying.
Just fucking raw anger and all it is is just an easy target.
That's all it is.
It's just an open,
easy target.
What you're supposed to do,
you're not supposed to go,
this is fucking bullshit.
This is what passes for fucking music.
No,
that's not what he's supposed to,
we're supposed to do is go,
oh,
this isn't for me because I'm not 14 right.
Not get angry.
Just move on with your life.
But some people,
man,
they just want to get on youtube when your motto,
fuck,
I want you to feel what I feel.
Yeah.
Ah,
fucking spa.
They just went up sweaty,
sweaty fingers pecking down on the keys.
God,
I see people like got my message board all the time.
Just get cunty with somebody for no reason.
I'll just,
I'll just send them to the special ed room.
Get Out,
get out.
Stop that.
You don't have to do that for no reason.
You don't have to just shitty with people.
As far as I can recall,
I have never left of West shitty fucking car.
I just don't take the time to leave a shitty comment.
So silly.
I mean I left a single aim to,
yeah,
I've gotten in a bunch of those.
But what people don't understand about flame wars,
this is kind of like a competition,
you know,
it's sorta like the dozens,
like you play the dozens,
you know,
if you don't know what it is,
it's like,
you know,
your Mama's so fat.
You know,
once you sit down,
people think she's a sofa,
you know,
and you go back and forth.
He insult each other.
You know what I mean?
Like it's like a big thing.
Like with the brothers,
they love,
they love to play the dozens.
That's what it's called.
But that's sort of like with flame wars are,
it's like it's kind of fun that were all anonymous,
right?
And so you kind of like just up to your wits.
It's just you and your wits against somebody else and their wits.
And all of a sudden you get in some conti little argument with someone online
and you want to fucking rock on,
man.
You would sit back and let me craft my words carefully here.
I'm gonna fuck you up bitch.
And I love watching it as a sport.
I like watching like smart people like go back and,
and the really conti thing to do is to have a sentence and then respond with a
big chunk.
And then another sentence and [inaudible] with a big chunk where it's like
you're taking little,
it's such a bully move where you're taking like little,
a sentence,
a little tiny segment of what someone said and not in the greater context of
several paragraphs of writing,
but just one little sentence.
And then they'll respond to it with a goat,
a river of shit.
Yep.
And you go back and forth and back and forth.
I've done that.
I've done it.
It's stupid.
I don't do it anymore.
I occasionally I do,
but for the most part I just try to be silly with it.
But in the past,
man,
I've gotten involved in like long flame wars with people that went on for days.
Well,
I mean if you think of it like imagine if if youtube had existed when Buddha
incarnated on the planet,
so like he could like upload his ideas on to Youtube.
It would still have shitty comments.
Like what a fucking joke.
You idiot.
What are you talking about?
Life is suffering.
Go sit under the tree some more faggot.
They will be like that.
When you,
what do you think
when you hears that though?
I mean don't you have a little bit of an instinct to say the same thing.
Life is suffering.
Oh,
profound one please,
please ponder on when you get your Dick sucked.
Cause that suffering.
No,
no,
no.
It's not.
When you're in an awesome movies.
That's how I got this.
Not when you're on stage,
you're killing is that sounds like.
Let me,
no,
hold on.
When you're hanging out with your,
is it suffering?
No,
it's not.
If you have a nice car and it's comfortable and you get a good stereo and the
creed song comes on,
is that suffering?
No.
It's not Buddha.
Buddha's life sucked cause Buddha didn't have cool shit or cool friends.
That's wrong.
Yeah.
He had a whole bunch of chipmunks and actually said that's wrong.
No,
that's knows.
Well,
the nose
go way back.
History is very vague,
but my relationship with Buhler secrecy,
is that okay?
No,
but the thing when you're saying good,
a shitty life there,
there's the story of Buddha and Buddha's started off as a a very wealthy prince
and there was a problem.
What year?
I have no idea
that life sucked.
It doesn't matter what it does.
I don't care if it's according center BC,
six,
seven,
eight d and a Harem.
He had a Harem.
Yeah,
that's good.
It's stinky girls with no razors,
a razor insight.
Everybody's disgusted and the time I,
they're all scratching for food and has a pretty good line of heroin.
Get the fuck Outta here.
Listen,
man,
it was a terrible time to live.
Terrible.
No Internet,
no cell phones,
no refrigerator,
no vaccines,
no fucking right US military presence overseas.
Listen as a terrible God damn time to live.
Fuck Buddha ideas.
Ridiculous life is not suffering life.
The rest of the noble truths.
Oh well hold on.
You said no bull fight.
Said No.
That's what they're called.
But
she just does the most for type of thing a human can ever say.
Do you know the noble truths?
That's what they're called.
I understand that.
I'm just fucking around here.
These are just jokes.
Don't get personal.
He takes it very personal.
No,
I don't.
I like to shit on boot every now and just to get a ride.
Just off.
You sound like you don't know what it is.
You could pick on Dunkin and he won't even fight back,
but you're talking about Buddha who will fucking kick your ass,
dude.
But it would be like step up and dug and dug and Doug
in front of the UFC and being like,
you know,
cause they're fight.
They fight eight rounds and then you'd be like,
well no,
they don't.
No.
Would be no rules,
no rules.
Where you're like,
it's a clique like you.
Clearly.
If you don't know what it is.
Well Dude,
it was all at brown brother,
brother.
I'm telling jokes,
man,
I'm not,
I don't believe any of this shit.
I'm saying,
well,
you're thinking Buddha's a loser who you're hurting.
You got it.
Yeah.
You don't know.
Totally gone against the whole truth of Buddha.
We need to really believe in him.
All I'm saying is I wouldn't want to live back then.
I wouldn't either.
I'm not saying the Buddha was wrong when he said life is suffering.
It just sounds a little pretentious and if somebody said it today,
life is suffering,
I would want to probably kick them.
Right.
There's three other things after that.
Oh,
okay.
Go ahead.
So this,
the second one is the cause of suffering is attachment to things staying the way
they are.
The idea that things aren't going to change,
so is suffering.
In other words,
you're suffering when you think things don't change.
Oh.
So what I did is basically the exact same thing that I criticized people doing
on the message boards where they take one line,
don't even read the rest of it.
I didn't even listen to their whole sentence.
I took one one line and I just tack boots and socks.
I don't really mean any of the things I say.
I say thanks for the fun of it.
Okay.
I really do have Buddhas.
I have fucking boot Tattoo on my arm.
Come on man.
I'm fascinated by Buddhists.
That's one of the things I first saw during psychedelic experiences.
The Golden Buddha made of light.
Yeah.
Golden Buddha in the Lotus position.
And then there was like infinite numbers of them around them.
Like fractals of Golden Buddhas in the lowest position.
Oh it was one of the craziest experiences,
right?
It's a core religion man.
Cause it's a,
it's,
it's a viral religion,
which is,
it's very different from a lot of other world religions like Christianity and
Islam that kind of come into a place and try to change what's happening in the
place to conform to Christianity.
Buddhism goes into a place and like analyze is whatever the belief system is in
that place,
and then incorporates that into the philosophy of Buddhism.
So you get these fastly different forms of Buddhism all over the planet,
like a,
and I like Tibetans.
If you look at Zen Buddhism and then you look at Tibetan Buddhism,
they couldn't be more different.
And Zen Buddhism is,
it's very austere.
Um,
if you look at a zen monastery,
the walls,
I,
I've never been in one,
but the walls are made of rice paper and like to like these guys fucking sitting
there and meditating for like just spinning their whole life meditating.
It's very,
very stark.
Then you look at Tibetan Buddhism and it's like Golden Buddhas and prayer wheels
and prayer flags,
and it's like this bright,
beautiful thing.
And the reason is,
is when Buddhism came to,
to bet there was a religion called Bon bon,
that was the original religion,
and it just took that religion and transformed it.
So that embodied the noble truth of Buddhism.
Wow.
Isn't that cool?
Just hybrid the hybrid.
Yeah.
That's what it does.
It,
it,
it infects,
uh,
infects probably the wrong word,
but it gets into a culture and then just the culture.
Sex is a great word.
Yeah,
that's what I mean.
It's,
it's sort of a negative word.
Yeah.
Well,
I mean that is what it is.
It kind of,
it's viral.
It like gets into the DNA of a thing and then transforms it into,
uh,
Buddhism.
That's fascinating.
Fascinating.
It really is.
You know,
it,
I've always wondered like what the boundaries of Meditation Army,
cause I don't really have the time to be sitting around all day meditating,
but I always feel like anything like even the isolation tank,
which is very much like a,
um,
a symptom or a rather a,
a,
um,
a method of meditation,
the isolation tank you,
the more you do it,
the better you get at it,
right?
The more relaxed you get when you're,
you're inside,
the easier it is for you to let go,
the easier it is for you to get to that really crazy deep state.
So I would assume that with meditation,
just like with anything with music or arts,
the
more time you spend at at the better you get at,
I would wonder what,
what the fuck can you do with your brain if you have like 10,
12 hours a day.
Cause you know,
Eddie Bravo has this friend of his,
he went to Egypt with this lady and uh,
she um,
was uh,
a Kundalini efficient auto,
like a serious divo tay of Kundalini Yoga and this lady did Kundalini Yoga all
fucking day.
And what she said was that it was all about stimulating particular areas of your
brain that can produce psychedelic chemicals and that what you're trying to do
is like open up your shockers and you can tune it into higher frequencies of
consciousness.
And that these people say that at the highest levels that these,
these people are capable of putting themselves into a psychedelic state.
Absolutely.
Naturally.
So like what you would have to do by taking mushrooms are taken payoti or
whatever.
They can just meditate and get there and they travel in their mind to like
distinct,
different places.
And the idea is that what they're doing is they're literally changing the form
of their mind.
If you look at the mind of a,
a person who meditates,
you know,
a Buddhist monk,
he person who meditates 10 12 hours a day,
their,
the way their brain works is different.
The size of different areas of the brain is different.
The,
the,
when they look at the activity in the mind,
it's different than a regular person's brain.
Yeah,
I've seen that stuff.
Fascinating.
So you mean they,
what?
Tuning into higher,
like a higher plane of consciousness,
if that is what they're doing that they're able to do.
Just like,
I mean,
what we see in marathon running,
just like what we see in everything,
you know,
like who could you run a marathon?
I couldn't run a fucking marathon.
Could you imagine if you got to run a marathon right now against one of those
skinny guys from Africa that runs barefoot fucked.
You're fucked.
You're never going to run as fast as he never going to catch.
I'm never gonna be able to run 26 miles as fast as him,
but he can do it.
And you know what that means?
You could probably do it too,
but it doesn't start like that.
It starts with you run one mile and then you learn to run five miles and you
build yourself up.
So you can run 26 miles barefoot.
But most people can't just do,
do that right from the jump.
That's gotta be the same way with meditation.
Because I know that when I meditate,
I can get into a really good state just when I'm alone,
I'm alone in a hotel room.
I'll do like yoga and I'll do,
and then I'll meditate.
I'll go into a certain pattern of breathing and our focus and concentrate on my
breath.
And when I do that,
I can achieve a good perspective.
I can achieve like a,
a good objective look at at life and I can,
I can relieve myself of,
uh,
you know,
any unnecessary concerns and,
and I,
and like I,
I'm pretty good at that.
But I would imagine then if you really devote yourself to really just
concentrating on achieving like the,
the,
the possibilities of this different states of consciousness.
We linked to I think
to,
you'd be able to get high.
I did this thing,
uh,
because I,
I I studied,
uh,
I had to do this.
Uh,
um,
uh,
I studied uh,
religion and psychology in school.
So,
um,
I got to do an internship.
It is in temple and part of the internship is you do this thing called a saw
sheen,
which is where you sit for like three days straight.
It's just staring at this wall for three days straight and the Lotus position
and this,
and then you do,
well,
I went to do it and I,
I made it through,
okay.
I think like 11 hours of Matt and I made it through you sleep like four hours
and then the next day you wake up and immediate you eat and then you go right
back into meditating.
And so I made it,
I don't know,
I made it a pathetically small length of time because it was snowing outside.
And I started thinking about how good a beer with
sounding
no man,
I ain't man,
I love to drink a beer.
But like,
um,
but during the time that I was staring at the wall,
I don't know,
like six hours in or at some certain amount of time in,
they start doing this thing called the heart sutra.
They start chanting this thing called the Hartsutra.
Uh,
and it go,
and I don't remember the exact way it goes,
but it's something like no mine,
no body,
no life,
no death,
no beginning,
no.
It's very psychedelic.
It's very droney.
And it's a negation of everything.
No mine,
no.
But things.
Say it again.
I,
it's,
this is not an exact rendition,
but as I recall,
it's like no my,
no body,
no life,
no death,
no beginning.
No.
It's,
and they say this altogether.
Uh,
yeah,
they all start chanting.
It must be dope.
It's dope.
And you've been staring at a wall.
I don't know though.
You look at the body,
no mind.
No,
but not exactly a light show.
Death.
Let's just try that.
No.
Yeah,
no.
My,
no body,
no live,
no dad.
No,
my no body,
no live,
no death.
No.
Yeah.
I imagine that
there's some weird about that,
man.
What is weird about that play?
Look up the heart sutra on youtube and play it right.
There's some things are still were stoned as fuck,
but listen.
But what is weird about like chance man,
let's do it.
I ready.
No.
My no body,
no live,
no death.
No My,
no body,
no live,
no death.
There's something weird about that,
dude.
There's something xone.
There's something hypnotic about any stupid chant.
Even that you want to hear something super tripping you.
I think you could play it legally.
It's a cause.
It's a,
it's a chant.
You look up the Lotus suture on youtube.
Lotus Sutra,
the Lotus Sutra.
Listen to this one.
This one's so fucking trippy.
Yeah.
I mean what,
what would they're trying to do?
They're trying to put themselves into a state of consciousness by,
by humming lit like that.
Yeah.
It's got be the one I'm looking for it that
I'll show you the Warren.
Brian,
hold on.
Oh yeah.
That one at the very top,
but loaded suture play.
The first one with a blue flower right there.
Listen to this.
I love with dance and I'm high.
Okay.
[inaudible]
that was the 16 hundreds version of Pete boxing.
Crazy bad ass.
I'm scared that if they keep going,
candy man's going to come out of the screen.
I
get it.
Yeah.
It's cool man.
It's really trippy how odd.
It's almost like country music don't lead on with digital,
but if you listened to some of the,
like she,
she had,
he say it should bobo that the IOWASCA ceremonies.
If you listen to the chanting of the people in the Amazon,
it sounds very similar to that.
It's the same kind of like droney thing that has within it that feeling of like
a twinkie.
Weird like I dunno,
like something from New Orleans.
There's,
it's bluesy almost
very strange and how many different people are doing that?
You think it's not one person,
right?
That is a group of people for sure.
Congregation.
We're doing that.
I was a solid routine.
Did everybody have the same job?
That's what I'm saying.
But they all saying the same thing or whether people do people do different
harmonies and stuff when you do that champ?
Yeah,
that's what I'm thinking because it doesn't sound like you could like,
you know,
I don't know.
I mean maybe it could.
I mean sure you could like think of what the noises that Michael Winslow guy
makes.
I mean you probably could do it but it doesn't seem like,
that seems like a couple of different things are being said at the same time.
Is that right?
Oh yeah.
No,
no.
It's one suture.
It's,
they're reading a scripture.
They're reading this thing called the Lotus Sutra,
which is this whole weird.
So they're all saying the same thing.
They're all making the same noises.
Yeah,
I think so,
man.
I did.
It does seem like there's something under the the opera girl sounding girl.
Yeah,
there was an option
girl to me.
Well maybe we should play it again cause it seemed to me that it was like a
couple different sounds.
Now they're saying the same thing.
You're saying it really fast.
It's a hum to it.
That makes you think might be something going on in the background,
but it's not.
They're hitting every now and then.
There's like a little intersection.
It's a harmony.
Every now and then though,
someone will break.
Right.
Cool.
Oh yeah.
They're starting at different times.
They're saying the same shit,
but I felt like Mellison.
Yeah,
they're trying to catch up.
Yeah.
Wow.
This is,
if you listen to this while Shermin thinking about trip,
I think
I would get all the knowledge in the universe.
I think that would make just shit go crazy.
Run over you like a river of diamond and crusted fish.
You wouldn't be able to catch it though.
It's so much knowledge,
but you wouldn't be able to grasp it.
Yeah.
It could be.
Could conflict your
trip up because that's where nam-myoho-renge-kyo comes from.
That's the Nami.
[inaudible] comes from the Lotus Sutra,
so when you hear the beginning of it,
it's meal.
[inaudible] he says Andreessen my hundred Nikki.
Gosh.
Wow.
How did you ever memorize all that shit?
Why had the chance to strangulation
again,
eight months and I don't even have,
I don't have the whole thing memorized.
I just have the different,
but you have some parts I have up until there's like tea,
there's two different prayers you do.
And I have the first one.
I can almost do that completely without the book.
And then the second one,
I have to do the book.
If I'm,
they have,
there's like a button.
How does all this get started?
What I mean you look at like how bizarre all that is and was psychedelic that
religion is,
how the hell do I get started?
What's the,
what's the history?
That's the fucking question man.
I mean,
you've got this,
this uh,
the uh,
Buddha who according to the story,
um,
wanted to be an aesthetic like when it will live with this live with is a Buddha
lived live with the king and the king.
There was a prophecy.
He's either going to be a great conquer her or this is a real human being.
Absolutely proven by history.
Ah,
man,
I think so.
I mean sure.
More provable than Jesus or I couldn't answer that.
I have no idea.
I mean,
it did to me.
It's like I,
it's not that much of a consideration because there's so many scriptures that
come from it.
There's clearly something there.
And it's like there are a bunch of interpretations,
I don't know.
But the story is called,
it's still,
it's not like it's in Buddhism,
it's different from Christianity.
Christianity,
some forms of Christianity.
They're like,
you must believe that Jesus Christ was the son of God.
They have to believe that for the magic toward Buddhism isn't quite like that.
Buddhism is more like test all of this.
Like test it.
Like you would be if you were buying gold,
like you would weigh and measure and test gold.
Cause you need to logically understand what this is it that you have to
logically,
it has to logically make sense to you.
And this is the Buddhism.
This is,
that's not all forms of it isn't,
but sounds like,
ah,
there's a great,
so you were,
you were telling me,
I'm sorry I interrupted you before and you were explaining that he lived with
the king.
Yeah.
He was the prince and the king didn't want him to,
uh,
cause the,
the uh,
the Prophet said he'll either be the war Tawfiq God of the wheel Turner,
like this great prophet that he was,
or he's going to be this conquer,
like it.
He's going to be like a world conquer.
And so his father was like,
Oh fuck that.
I don't want him to be a fucking profit.
I want him to be a world conqueror.
So I'm going to keep him locked up on the grounds that palace and give him
everything he wants.
You know,
a Harem,
whatever he wants,
he can have.
And so the story is he a,
I was out with his,
like,
I dunno,
he was out riding around.
He saw three sites and I,
I don't remember exactly what they were,
but I know one was a dying man.
One was one,
one was Artcorps.
He saw corpse and I diseased man and an aesthetic.
He saw these three things and he's like,
oh,
there's,
I'm more there.
All this pleasure that I'm getting in.
The pal is,
is temporary.
It's temporary.
It's not gonna.
Last,
I'm going to get old,
I'm going to die,
I'm going to get disease.
These are the,
the,
this happens to everyone.
There's no escape from this happens to everyone.
So I would,
so these pleasures I'm experiencing,
I would rather,
um,
figure out a way to have lasting permanent,
uh,
realization then this temporary transient shit.
So he went and became an aesthetic and he,
uh,
he like a starved himself to the point of death almost.
Cause he was like,
he was like,
did everything to the extreme.
So there's like statues of like starving Buddha.
Yeah,
I've seen those.
Yeah.
You,
you,
you told me about that.
Yeah.
Because you know that I have this thing about collecting Buddhist statues and
I've got a couple of Thai Buddhas and shit.
And then you,
you told me about this.
Yeah.
Starving Buddha.
I was like,
what are you talking about that you sent me a picture,
dude,
I almost thought it was a joke,
no tight on his face.
And he's like,
he's not eating anything because he's trying to go the route of the aesthetic
to,
um,
uh,
so that he could,
you know,
have realization and Brian put one of those pictures up,
man.
It's fucking cool of those starving Buddha cause they're creepy as fuck man.
I never had heard about this before.
Oh,
it's cool man.
It's how long did he do this in his life?
I don't know the time that he's ever,
and everyone has a story or the goals of this story.
Yeah,
this is it.
This is,
it all starts with this store.
And so then he,
um,
so that didn't work out.
So,
and then he,
he uh,
he ate and uh,
you know,
the aesthetics rejected him.
The aesthetics rejected him because he was eating and that this man who was head
shit.
Yeah,
he was,
he got really close to death that way.
I think there's a phone,
body one,
Brian,
if you back up,
there's some other ones that have like full body.
Well,
either way you see,
you get to get the picture.
That's creepy.
Who the fuck would want to keep that in their house.
If you go over a chick's house and she's got that starving Buddha in her house,
fucking run,
Bro,
but run.
Why would you want to look at that all day?
I wouldn't leave.
See the veins in his ribs.
It's creepy.
Yeah.
You don't want to look at it.
That's barely.
That's like a cartoon.
It's like he's getting mashed potatoes and it's an old training.
It's like he's about to eat a bowl of mashed potato.
It's calm.
He's an old tranny.
Starvings tranny giant bowl.
Come.
Um,
speaking of calm.
Hang on.
Was Fun.
Huh?
Have a good time.
Speaking of was England was fun.
What happened?
Well,
no ego.
I'll tell you this.
Oh No,
you came on Joe.
Not really.
I mean,
he sorta did.
Well,
Joe's fast.
That's like good.
We went,
we went to a,
a strip club for 10 minutes at a time.
10 minutes.
It was right next to this restaurant with this bomb ass Indian restaurant in
Birmingham,
and then we would stop in at this place.
So disaster.
Well that's Joe Rogan.
It wasn't that.
It's just,
oh no,
there were people coming up here,
take your picture.
But it was just so,
it wasn't weird a strip club ever.
And I'm trying to be as nice as possible.
The best way to say it is,
you'd be kind of shocked that those girls are strippers.
Wondering why you're going to say,
you know,
well it seems like there were other vocations that would have been better
choices for them.
Yeah.
It seems like I'm,
when they're guiding me are always telling them what to do.
You shouldn't have said stripper anyway.
Nice,
nice people.
But was,
we couldn't,
we couldn't do it.
We got in there and we just thought we were going to be able to sit down and
just have a beer and just laugh and Giggle,
you know,
for a little bit and then leave.
But we're getting bombed on.
Yeah.
It was pretty sad.
I mean,
it wasn't even like when I go to strip clubs,
aside from like the fact of like seeing hot naked girls dancing.
The other thing I like is the,
uh,
the eat the darkness.
Yeah.
Seediness and the darkness because it's funny to me cause it's all AI.
This is a cultural,
this is a result of a specific type of culture.
It's a,
it's an like this wouldn't work if people weren't sexually repressed.
This wouldn't work if people didn't wear clothes.
There's like so many weird cultural things that have to happen for a strip club
to even make sense.
So when you go into there and you see like,
you see the fucking weird relationship between the women who are trying to act
dirty and slutty and then the guys who are kind of like feel like they're
breaking the rules tonight.
You know what I mean?
It's a funny thing because it's like,
it really is nothing.
It's like you're looking at a naked girl mounting a fucking pole.
You're getting a lap dance.
It's just,
I went to a strip club once,
a Phil Hartman,
Phil Hartman was,
uh,
I was,
more people.
Got to see what that dude was like without being like Mr like clean family,
you know,
he was like,
he was like super concerned about his image.
Right.
But outside of that,
he would say like ridiculously dirty shit,
man.
He was always telling you the smell his fingers and say it was claiming it was
different people in the Cassady fingers.
Go ahead.
It's fine.
I mean it was like,
it was ridiculous.
He was really funny.
I mean to the point where they would get mad at him,
you know,
and he,
he cracked me up,
man.
He would,
he would,
he was a serious blazer.
Feel hard when used to get high every day.
Dude,
especially after work and like he was very professional.
But after work he would get biolase dude get blazed and go out on his boat.
Then I went to a strip club with him once.
I've never seen a guy who was,
because he was such a great guy who was so expressive and he was a genuinely
like friendly guy and this is a different era.
Okay.
We're talking about the early 1990s.
It was like 1995,
you know,
and it was like,
he was there and the girl was dancing in front of him and he was like,
like there was no shame in it at all.
He was so happy cause he was,
he was so happy and he was looking at her.
She goes,
hey,
just from,
I'll never forget his face,
look at and go,
Oh yeah,
that's beautiful.
That's beautiful.
Cool.
He was like smiling like pure and hopeful,
like you're beautiful.
Woo.
Like he was just happy.
It wasn't creepy.
Now that's great.
That's a girl's vagina and ask,
wow man,
I look,
I have fuck,
it's beautiful.
I love people like that.
I love that man.
That guy,
when he died,
that hurt,
that sucked.
That was a tough one.
He was a,
he was a really good guy,
man.
That was a tough one.
Did I ever tell you how I found out there was a girl who,
uh,
I think she works for like one of those,
one of those tabloid shows we had went on one date.
But just,
you know,
for whatever reason,
it just didn't click.
So I was at home and it was like eight o'clock in the morning and the phone
rings and it's her and I'm like,
what's going on going?
Why are you calling me at eight o'clock in the morning?
And she's like,
you don't know.
And I go,
I don't know what.
And she goes,
I don't want to be the first one to tell you.
I go,
well fucking tell me what happened.
And then she goes,
fills dead.
And I go,
Phil Hartman.
And she goes,
yes.
She goes,
it was a murder suicide I want.
Whoa.
And first of all,
I thought he killed her and then killed himself.
He thought that first.
Yeah.
I mean,
I mean you hear murder,
suicide.
You just automatically think men are the ones who commit violent crimes.
That's how I am automatically.
Sure.
I don't think that ain't crazy.
Bitches are crazy.
And they would fucking shoot.
I always think I'm going to get shot by a girl.
I'm dating pool that you're drawing from side.
Good insight.
Yeah.
The dating cool that you draw from has been peed in?
Yes.
Assume,
I mean don't you?
When you hear about a murder suicide,
you assumed that it was the man.
I actually think around else.
I actually really,
wow,
man,
you're so nice and you're not violent at all.
Hang out with crazy guys and like,
I bet because you hang out with fighters and a bunch of Jujitsu guys,
you're around at different kind of animal than I'm used to.
I'm just stare like guys,
stop cards and stuff.
Jujitsu guys are,
they're very
friendly man.
You'd be amazed.
First of all,
they,
their ego gets squashed real early cause you get tapped out a lot when you learn
Jiu Jitsu,
especially in the early years,
you have to have a healthy ego or you'll never get through.
Being a white belt,
being a white belt is demeaning men.
Manhandle you,
you know,
it's,
I remember my first time I was trained at Carlson Gracie's on Hawthorne Street
is 1996 when I first started doing Jujitsu and there was this kid who was a
purple belt.
It's Brazilian kid.
He fucking over me,
just crushed me every time we roll.
And it drove me nuts because he wasn't any bigger than me.
He was my size,
he was my age,
we were the same and he would just fucking manhandle me did dude would just toss
me around and strangle me.
And I remember thinking like,
man,
I can't believe that it's so easy for someone to do this to me.
And then I knew like this guy was only a purple belt.
It wasn't even a black belt.
I'm like,
fuck.
Like that feeling is not a good feeling.
The feeling of getting your ass kicked like that and Jim is not a good feeling.
But the only way to get good is you got to get used to that.
You gotta,
you gotta roll with good guys.
If you don't roll with good guys,
you don't know whether or not you can really tap them.
You don't know whether or not you should only works on people who suck.
You gotta get tapped to tell you again,
you got to get in the beginning,
you got to get strangled all the time.
People got throw you around,
they're going to dominate you.
So if you can get through that,
usually your ego is a really a check.
Did you Jitsu guys are some of the friendliest,
nicest,
most easy going guys that I've ever been around.
Kickboxers are a little more edgy and one of the reasons is kickboxers they
don't go full out in the gym.
They sorted go,
they go hard.
But there's always like,
you're going too hard.
Like this is a thing that happens in standup gems.
It doesn't happen as much.
Happens occasionally but not as much in Jujitsu.
And that's someone going to hard because in standup it's always an issue because
you're not really fighting.
You have big gloves on.
The gloves are 16 ounces as opposed to four and when you're,
or you know,
eight or 10 if you kickboxing.
But when,
when you're throwing at each other,
you're supposed to be pulling back a little,
you know?
And so guys are always like,
yeah,
if I didn't pull back and go to fucking knock your ass out,
there's some unresolved issues with some guy.
So they,
some of them tend to be a bit more douchey.
It's like the,
and then the,
the,
the more like limited their sport is,
the more insecure they are and the more do,
should they like boxers or more douchey then kickboxers are more douchey.
And this is all generalizations,
but,
but for the most part,
Jujitsu guys and wrestlers seem to be like the most easy going.
They go at it all the time.
You know,
you,
you blow out all the stress out of your system and all that,
you know,
all that ego shit.
Especially what you just said,
you just getting,
you get tapped all the time.
You got to accept it.
Yeah.
Yeah man,
it's spooky when you run into people who have a shitload of pinup aggression.
Yes.
How's that?
Eric?
The Grove and I had parked,
wasn't the greatest parking job ever.
I'll admit it was a shitty parking job.
And I'm getting in my car and this old man is standing there looking at me.
He's like,
why did you park like that?
And so it's forcing this weird confrontation in a parking lot.
And I and the guys,
you know that thing when you get around someone and like you can feel your like
goosebumps that happen.
Like they're thinking about hitting you or something.
Yeah.
Like your body's telling you like this is not a good situation that was
happening and it's like this old man,
I'm like,
fuck,
this could be that thing where the guy's got a gun and he just,
this is where pops,
this is where
the volcano explodes.
And I ended up getting blasted in the grove
and they catch it in the background of Mario Lopez's each show.
Yeah.
So he's got a show going on somebody and some old man shoots here.
That's the worst people fucking that all the time.
People get smoked all the time by people who are like have these little volcanic
explosion place at the wrong time.
It's a real,
it's a real scenario.
I uh,
the other day I was driving and there was a biker in the road and he was like
doing one of those things where he was like wobbling.
Like,
I think the guy was drunk or something like,
and I just like kind of tried to go around them and then I just,
I did a,
I didn't do the horn the whole way.
I did like a,
you know,
like when you just barely touch it and it makes a noise,
not even allowed at all and he's just like,
starts screaming.
And you know what?
I never saw that boulder,
boulder,
Colorado.
You know why 100,000 people?
That's why that's how you're supposed to live.
You're not supposed to live like this,
but man,
there's some aggro bikers in La.
Man,
I saw,
I saw it.
Remember that guy?
Just many fucking people in la.
You're,
you're crazy.
You're taking a huge risk if you're riding a bike places.
I mean,
I've seen her right to do it and I'm cautious of bikes.
I try to be cautious,
but wow.
I look at them.
I'm like,
what a crazy risk you're taking,
dude.
I've seen so many hipster bike accidents in silver lake.
Oh,
we were walking down the sidewalk and you see a,
you know,
hers did have a record store.
They were at dance like they were biking one hand and a couple of books and then
you come up to like a fucking hipster having a seizure.
I've seen a hipster on the sidewalk seizing up is the ambulance came out library
books and Oh my God,
weird like lace crash,
no helmet on,
no helmet,
no helmet crashes and just,
but I saw,
I saw a fucking minivan just pull into a parking lot and wasn't paying attention
and just t bone,
a biker.
Oh my 12th.
Just fucking dangerous.
So I understand why bikers here freaking out.
But do you remember that guy?
The comedy store?
There was a biker.
They used to ride up and down sunset and he was this super aggro biker fucking
ripped.
And I saw a guy yell at him and his car.
Like what you did a comic?
No.
So just some bicycler used to hang out.
It's always there,
always there.
And he was always pissed and he's always screaming at traffic and I remember
like some car was like watch out cause he's just weaving in and out of traffic
and the guide is stops his bike because I don't think people realize that with
bikers were just so you still in cars,
there's this like I can get away from you.
I can say something a bicycler can weave through traffic at a stop light and
just attack you like they can get you.
We forget that there's no enclosure around them.
We forget that people have like gotten used to like to delay and violence
between cars where you're like,
well fuck you.
It's too much work.
I don't get out of the car and fucking get all the way to
you.
These guys an open fucking air and he's like weaving in and out of sunset
boulevard traffic and he's deranged and so some idiot says something to him and
the guy,
this is what he's been waiting to happen.
He like stops his bike turns and looks at the guy and not this,
you could just hear he meant this.
He's like,
I'm going to put you in the hospital,
I'm going to break your fucking jaw is what he said.
And it was just such venom and evil and anger spewing out of this.
He didn't,
he didn't people.
Yeah.
You can't be a cut.
There's people that want to punch people if you've run into and your cut.
Yeah.
But I mean,
isn't it interesting that we have this sort of uh,
uh,
escalated anger that exists in inside cars because we don't have to socially
interact with each other.
We don't have to like feel it.
Yeah.
You know,
we are going to have to feel the repercussions of social repercussions of being
a shithead so people just get so elevated and cars
pot when you see it,
like SUV is,
I don't think I could ever go back down to like a small little car cause he feel
more protected in an Sua cause this shit goes down.
You just run the person over and go over and you know,
a couple of cars and escape
knew who watched too many movies.
How did you get a flat?
The fuck are you talking about?
Yeah,
it's weird how you just assume.
But it's funny also the things that people say when they're in cars.
There's a video of a Nick Diaz and he had missed a press conference and he was
supposed to go and fight George San Pierre but they pulled him from the fight
cause he missed a couple of press conferences.
So he made a video about it.
And this is a video,
like a public video and he's in his car and as he's drive and making this video,
he was,
someone won't let him in.
He's like,
let me and let me fuck your mother.
Fuck your mother.
When people say Shit like that.
That's funny man.
Cause he wouldn't say fuck your mother if you were right in front of them.
If you like some lady.
But you know.
But if you're a leg,
if it's a lady and then she's in a car in front of you,
you don't even have to worry about hurting their feelings.
You can say the most ruthless
Liz Shit Dude,
when I'm driving I try to chant to relax.
So I'll need to do I.
Yes I do.
So I'll be chanting when I'm driving like knickers,
knickers,
not,
I got it.
I'm on and I'm driving through traffic.
Eight drives.
I'm chanting to relax and inevitably someone will cut me off and in the middle
of chanting I'd be like,
Yo,
you stupid fucking bitch.
Oh,
that's hilarious.
That's what's really there.
You do?
That's a joke.
You should say,
fuck.
Yeah.
That's hilarious.
You should talk about that on stage.
You could,
you could go far with that content.
That's cool.
Yeah.
Well that's the unavoidable stress of living in cities.
There's too much tension.
This,
this is not healthy.
You know,
we're all,
we're all a red lining everyday.
Yeah.
It's so weird.
Small communities are nicer.
It's just the,
you know,
y'all,
you deal with or you used to deal with in the age before the Internet,
you dealt with a lot more small minded people.
You dealt with a lot more religious Wackos.
If you wanted to live in the woodland,
the middle of nowhere,
it's tough to get away from the really,
really religious people.
You know what,
man?
I had a,
uh,
speaking of religious people,
I had a,
a real
American moment today where I was like,
man,
this is a pretty good country.
I was,
cause they cause like,
you know,
the uh,
inception at birth thing that just got overturned.
Do you know about this?
No.
What does that so I can't,
can you see where it was,
man?
Was it a ma?
I can't remember where it was.
Uh,
can you look at faith for me?
Oh,
pro turf tilt the logo of your mic towards you.
Yeah.
You're talking to the side?
No,
no.
That logo on the front of them.
There's a thing on the right here in the mix.
You're like this?
Yeah.
So it's around here.
Look at the part where it's written and the point that towards your face.
Gotcha.
See it.
Yeah.
I got it.
There you go.
Ooh,
that sounds so much better.
Hello?
There you go.
You're back.
Yeah,
man.
It's like person hooded at conception.
You another water.
Yeah,
I think that's what it's called.
It's called person.
So the,
I like,
it's this thing where they want it basically.
They want to say that.
I can't remember the exact words for it.
They have exact word for it.
I can't remember the term.
Okay.
Say it again.
Can set like say Ooh,
look up conception,
personhood at conception or it's the ideas like w when you can,
when can set,
when conception happens,
uh,
when,
when when the fucking eggs are in the uterine wall and are fertilized by a sperm
that is now a human being.
That's a person.
So they were trying to pass that which would make all forms of abortion illegal
and maybe even birth control depending on like how you look at it.
I,
so anyway,
it got overturned.
The voters overturned it and they were thinking it wouldn't get overturned,
but it was like super religious fundamentalists were trying,
when you see overturned,
you mean it passed?
It didn't pass.
So they thought it was going up.
There it is.
Well isn't overturned mean something person has passed and then overturned?
No,
I'm sorry it didn't get voted for.
It didn't make it in.
Is that a measure that didn't get voted for?
It lost and people were saying it was going to,
uh,
it was going to win.
So it was cool.
The political system in that one case worked where they thought it wouldn't
carry shit.
Scary Shit.
Well,
you know,
it's awesome,
Gary,
when you think about what abortion really is,
you know,
that's scary too.
I mean this,
you're,
you're taking a baby and you're sucking out of your pussy with a
me too expensive.
Well,
there's different,
you know what man,
I'm,
there's a lot of versions of abortion that I think are fucking horrible and I,
and I totally am not four,
but there is some,
there is definitely cases.
Oh yeah.
Whereas Shit where's should happen?
And you can not only that,
how about,
yeah,
you know,
it's up to the person that's carrying that baby baby inside of them until the
baby's born.
It's up to them.
I mean,
I think if,
you know,
if you have an aborted kid that's perfectly healthy and it's like six months old
inside your body,
like that's kind of crazy.
But I know that people have done that in the past.
I think if it's not for a medical reason,
it's not,
you know,
and I don't know if it's those fucking partial birth abortions.
You know about those,
right?
Yeah.
They ice pick the fucking brain of the baby.
It's a baby.
I mean that's,
I think that's,
that's not,
that definitely shouldn't happen.
That's crazy.
It's almost like I don't see it.
Yeah,
I don't see it.
I'll say,
yeah,
I know he's talking about La la,
la,
la.
That's why I just put a blanket on your baby.
Why don't you give birth to the thing and cover it and a blanket.
Take it since it's inside the pussy and you see me sticking the icepick
in his head and it's all fine.
It's okay.
It was outside and I jab it in front of you and then chopped it up into pieces.
He'd be like,
you just killed the anymore.
If it came out for a second and you put it back in,
couldn't do it.
Same Baby.
But if you pulled it out of the vagina and put it back in,
you couldn't ice pick at once.
It been in the air.
The rule is once it's been in the air,
you can't kill it as a person that's alive.
Yeah.
That's fucked up.
That doesn't make sense or easy is it?
Yeah,
it's really strange.
I mean,
and you know,
it's,
this is a taboo subject.
This is a subject you're supposed to,
if you're a rational,
open minded person,
you're supposed to just favor choice.
You know?
Which I,
I do.
Yeah.
I mean,
I don't,
I don't think any should we be,
I think it's a real slippery slope.
It's a real slippery slope when someone tells you what you can and can't do with
your body.
You know,
it seems like you're killing a baby,
but I guess he should be able to do it.
You know what these are,
and we've discussed this before,
it's so much easier when it's a small couple of cells.
It's much easier to rationalize,
but it's on its way to being a baby,
you know?
Well,
just,
I,
it depends on where the thing is,
you know?
And,
and it depends on it'll,
it depends on a lot of different things.
It's like everyone wants to make these sweeping things like [inaudible].
The two sides of it are.
It should all the two extreme sides are.
It should be.
It should be illegal no matter what.
Even if that rapist impregnated the woman and the baby's going to kill her,
then h she should have that baby and we'll raise the baby.
Can
I have his name?
Say his name.
His name,
Lord Jesus Christ.
We were raised that rapists baby Jesus Christ,
and he could be the next president.
Now that's very stumble.
What's that?
Do you see Rick Perry stumbled?
Yeah.
It was awesome.
It was hilarious.
It was such a fucking,
it was uncomfortable to watch.
That was hilarious to think that you don't know that.
Yeah.
He forgot.
You don't know that.
You forgot that.
Yeah.
You're running for president.
How the fuck are we going to let you keep track of the world's military
presence?
Isn't he the executioner?
Isn't Rick Perry the one who had like shit loads of people he executed in Texas,
Texas?
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
He,
he's living controversial ones.
He sends him to the Fryer.
Yeah.
They send a lot of them to the FRY,
which,
you know,
listen,
if people are cons,
I kind of liked that.
I liked getting rid of him,
but I don't trust the political system.
That's a problem.
Yeah.
That's the,
that is it.
That's number one.
But Rick Perry's it.
You got to break a few eggs to make an omelet.
Kind of guys.
Like if I got to fucking kill a couple of Nice people to fry a bunch of
assholes,
then well that's the price you pay for.
Uh,
for liberty.
Yeah.
He is one of those guys,
right?
Yeah.
That's what he's like.
He's,
you know,
he's a,
he's a fucking assholes.
What he is,
man.
I mean,
you can't,
it's like that's the main thing.
Until we perfect the system,
the death,
the government,
they'll legal system.
You can't have the death penalty.
You can't,
it,
it's not,
part of being a citizen of the United States does not mean that you've got to
race being falsely imprisoned and executed.
Uh,
because the legal system isn't perfect.
That's wrong.
You into.
You can't give the ultimate punishment
unless you've really perfected the system.
We know till we know 100% I know there's way better methods now than they've
ever been before.
When you include genetics and just,
I've watched CSI,
I'm pretty sure I'm up to what they're up to,
but still it was still fucking,
there's a lot of doubt in some cases.
Is this in is also fucking shady cops,
man.
There's people plant evidence.
They plant evidence.
It happens all the time.
You know,
it's,
it's not something that's never taken place in the history of man.
It is most certainly taking place.
It's been proven.
So you,
you got to know your system is fucking air tight and it's just not.
I'll say,
what if someone actually reforms?
Yeah.
While they're in prison.
What if someone has actually now at a good person,
are you still going to kill him?
It depends on what they did.
If they kill people,
say,
Eh,
I'm biblical on that man.
You're Shiria on that.
Yeah.
My friend Sharia law,
I think there's a,
there's certain justifiable homicides,
you know,
I think,
I believe in that.
I believe in,
if someone's trying to kill you,
like I heard this a story who told me the star was at you about the death metal
band.
Yeah.
You tell me.
Tell me the story you told me on the plane.
Yeah.
Okay.
So here's the story.
There's a perfect example of justifiable homicides.
The at documentary on Norwegian death metal that I saw on Netflix.
So if I fuck up this story for death metal fans out there,
I apologize,
I'm going to tell it as best as I can remember it.
But so the idea is there is,
it's Ah,
it's about Burzum there.
Basically it's about this group,
you know,
like how like Ah,
where did punk form did pot?
We're in,
in the UK forms and there's like a group of like punk bands.
Wherever there's an art movement,
there's a group of artists who are like the core of the,
the movement or even in like music,
you know,
like with gangster rap,
there was Nwa,
there's a bunch of tea,
right?
And they all kind of formed together.
So Norway's answer to that is Norwegian death metal.
Where are these fucking guys decide that they're going to go hard core and be
like truly,
truly as dark as you can get.
Terrible people.
Terrible.
Well they like,
so they started burning down churches.
They started going through the countryside,
burning down churches and a one in one of the bands,
one of the band members,
uh,
it was so depressed because he's a in the death metal and that's all they think
about his death,
that he goes back to his house,
puts a gun in his mouth and blows his brains out.
And the other guy in the band comes to the house,
sees his dead body,
takes a picture of his fucking head and uses that as the cover their next town.
Shit.
Fucking hardcore man.
So they're burning down churches and uh,
Burzum,
uh,
Burzum hears that this other guy who was this competitor or these,
he was a and had some history where the ear that this guy was saying,
yeah,
I'm going to,
I'm going to kill.
I'm going to kill him.
I'm just going to kill him.
And uh,
he was bragging about how he's going to kill him.
So this guy's like,
oh well,
okay.
He wants to kill me.
He's going to kill me so I'm going to have to kill him first.
And he got in his car and he drove to where the guy was fucking executed.
The Guy,
he killed him.
He went to jail is in jail and Norway.
Oh play Burzum receiving his life sentence.
Wait to see this.
Can we play that on Youtube?
Oh I think so.
So he gets like not wives than it is a movie.
Brian,
how is here,
I'm noticing this before we play this,
how would you have me reversed?
You have my left hand.
My right hand and my right hand,
my left hand.
It's so freaking me out.
It's so that they,
it looks like we're all talking to each other.
Oh that's cool.
Oh that's so bizarre.
Yeah.
Look up.
Uh,
Burzum received senates and it's really weird cause the guy gets like a 27 year
sentence in prison cause that's how they can give in Norway and he gets it.
Yeah.
And he gives the creepiest smile.
Whoa.
He just saw.
How many years have you been in for?
I think,
I don't know.
I don't follow a death metal that much.
You can only get 27 years old and what you did,
something like that.
God,
I feel like,
I'm sorry man.
You guys.
If I know,
I feel like I've thrown out some like wonky facts.
We have a fuzzy understanding of everyday.
The guy's name again.
Uh,
Burzum.
B,
U,
R,
z u m
Vlade Vlade something [inaudible] or something.
Vlade vagueness.
Yeah.
Let me see.
Yeah,
that's him.
What does it say?
Yeah,
this one.
That's the guy who did it.
That's the guy.
They were burning down churches,
man.
They were burning down these antique wooden churches if someone wanted to kill
him.
Yeah,
Greg,
that shit.
Let me hear that.
All right.
Fit and lift.
Fucking city.
[inaudible] [inaudible]
[inaudible] [inaudible] selves is fine.
Okay.
That's gets fucking prison in Norway is like a country club.
Is it really?
Oh yeah,
man.
It's nice,
dude.
They've got nice prisons there.
Really?
Yeah.
It's not like the US prisons.
They Norway's got this really fucking intense ethic about reforming people.
They really want to reform people.
Their prison systems are based on reformation rather than revenge.
Like in the United States.
It's like exacting punishment.
We must punish you.
We are going to take it out of your hide there.
They're like,
look,
let's,
let's try to fix them.
Maybe there's a way to make it so that,
uh,
they don't go back into society,
you know,
as criminal stuff,
we might be able to just fix them,
you
know,
fix the problem.
Wow.
Cause I mean the death penalty you don't have,
how do you feel about that?
I think it's genius.
You think it's,
it does it work?
Uh,
I dunno.
I Dunno the,
you know,
if it works,
it's great.
You know,
when we were in England,
do you remember,
uh,
there was a moment where like I was talking to the crowd about how polite people
are in England.
Like is this crazy?
Like this is so different than America.
The way people act and the way people behave,
the crowds,
they're just so different.
And in Norway,
they're probably like pretty Nice folks for the most bat.
Right.
This is what they're trying to do.
Yeah.
You know what I mean?
Think how nice and friendly people are in England.
And this is probably,
it's probably real similar in Norway.
It's almost like that system has to be in place almost from the get go.
It's like once you get as rotten as the,
the,
the prison system that we have today to take those people and just shoved them
in the country clubs and make everything nice and fun and easy.
Well,
we,
but we don't see,
the thing is,
man,
we,
there's so many other,
well,
you know,
there's the,
what do they call it?
What did,
can I call him?
Does he think that that would ever possibly work?
You have to,
I think you have to make sense.
Some,
uh,
pharmaceuticals,
you have to be able to legally give them mushrooms and psychedelics in
combination with like really radical therapies to reform them.
And I,
we're not along the way they're thinking and you can't do that now.
You can't do that now.
But they used to,
Timothy leary was doing it with a Alpert.
They were doing,
uh,
experiments with rev reforming prisoners,
and they would go into jails and eat mushrooms with the prisoners.
They would trip with the prisoners.
Whoa.
Yeah.
And it was a,
you know,
it's,
it's anyone who's done a psychedelic,
if you think about it,
you're like,
oh yeah,
this could really,
this.
If anything can,
uh,
fix a person's deep psychic problems,
this could do it if was,
if it was done the right way,
you know,
but we,
because of the,
what is,
uh,
what did mechanical at the pharmacological inquisition that is happening right
now,
these substances are you,
you can barely even experiment with them.
And now that they have Johns Hopkins University is saying,
Oh yeah,
if you eat mushrooms,
it'll improve your personality.
Yeah.
You know,
so,
so maybe that's the key.
Maybe,
you know,
the,
the Hopkins study will lead to more studies,
which will lead to,
you know,
treatments for like,
people who have,
are all these studies when they get,
do they do these studies?
All these people they're taking,
these studies are usually people that need money and probably are depressed
anyway.
So the probably made everybody's life a happy.
They see the thing is mandate.
I mean like if they don't take like really nice wealthy,
uh,
golfers that are retired on Florida go,
hey,
take this study.
They're probably taking like people that need the a quick $300.
No,
they're very strict about it.
They have like when they do,
when they're getting applicants,
especially for big studies like these,
they have like that's part of the,
when the FDA is approving this shit,
right.
That's part of,
that's a big part of what they go through.
It's like where are you getting your control group?
Where are you getting your,
where are you getting your group from the,
you're doing the study on.
Because if it was like you're thinking about the way they do tests for TV shows,
you know what I'm saying?
That like is the studies like the same that I used to do in college or are these
studies like a bunch of poor people?
Are they a mix of these studies?
Because the John Hopkins study where they're studying students,
you can look up,
there's like housewives and the Johns Hopkins Studies.
They were like intentionally trying to find people who are like not as familiar
with mushrooms or hadn't taken them because it needed a quick few hundred
dollars for this study.
You know what I'm saying?
That's what I was saying.
Yeah.
I,
you know,
I don't,
I don't know man.
And to your point,
because all those people,
if they take mushrooms,
their life's going to feel better because they're fucking,
I don't like,
to me,
I don't like eating mushrooms and I'm fucking broke.
And if I was in a,
I don't know that,
I don't know that.
I don't know the income.
I know that sucks.
When you're tripping and you start thinking about bills,
that's a fucking shitty.
Well,
yeah,
it depends on how much it weighs on you.
For some people,
um,
when you're broke,
it's,
it's all day.
It weighs on you.
Other people could just kind of brush it off and they don't,
they don't seem to give a fuck.
I consider it a party drug,
like I want to fucking leave this reality.
I want to,
it's just get the fuck out of this.
That's what you consider Masha?
Yeah.
Yeah,
I do too.
But along the way,
uh,
you know,
it's,
Oh,
it's always this white knuckle ride.
We,
you're scared as far before you do it.
And then once you do it,
you realize,
God,
why was I ever scared of this?
And then after it's over you,
you know,
you sort of assess whatever you've kind of absorbed whatever fish you've caught
and you're golden net.
That's cool man.
No,
yeah,
you catch some fish.
I have,
but I never mushrooms,
I've never thought of them as like a park go out party drug.
I,
you know,
like in the o and the days when I would take it a acid was that like I could go
out and like have fun or like go out into the,
I wanted to go,
I'd go to,
like,
when I was a kid,
you go to shopping malls and trip just
for get to a point where you weren't lucid.
Like you couldn't communicate with LSD.
Yeah.
Like we were talking,
you are out and you're talking to people and you just can't keep it together.
Like you can't communicate with them.
Ah,
you not when I was out,
I mean I've taken,
like I took a really powerful dose and tried to have a conversation with a girl.
I always take,
I was taking it with,
and I sounded like a schizophrenia.
I was having like word salad cause like we had just gone to some Greek festival
and I had watched these little kids dancing and,
and I was like sitting watching these kids like doing some weird Greek
traditional dance.
And it was like,
it felt like I could see through the concrete and it,
I felt like there was like,
it just felt like this beautiful moment where it was like,
the universe is like,
you know,
the,
this is like watching a flower.
Like it's a traditional weird dances.
It's so cool the way the universe can express beauty in that way.
And Yeah.
So I was like tripping and sitting on the couch and I'm trying to like tell her
universe,
wow.
Flower Brie.
Beautiful God.
Yeah.
You know,
I kind of word salad just cause I was so like spellbound and also tripping.
So are my language centers have gotten fucked up.
I mean,
when you see someone on a heavy dose of acid,
they have a problem.
They like
their language gets all mixed up and weird.
My last shrimp thing,
I couldn't even walk.
I,
that was the first time I ever did a second dog where I couldn't use my feet.
I fell two.
Wow.
That's crazy.
Fell to the ground.
The presence of Jay's up.
Praise his name.
Dude.
You want to hear my podcast prayer?
Yeah,
I do.
But uh,
I wanted to ask you something and I just forgot what I wanted to ask you.
Um,
oh.
Oh.
Did you know that Ted Kaczynski was involved in the Harvard LSD study?
You told me that fucking crazy man.
There's a whole documentary about it.
It's not an American one.
It's called the net.
And it's all about how they caught him and saw about what,
you know,
how he got started and he,
there's,
I think there's certain people that are accusing that study of a wrecking his
brain,
you know,
and that he was a fairly normal guy.
And once he went through the LSD study,
they cut down.
They cooked his mind.
Yeah.
And they probably gave him crazy high doses.
I don't think they do it.
I don't think they knew back then.
They didn't know they were fucking around.
You know,
I think there was a lot of experiments,
no way.
They knew man.
They were just fine.
Who knows?
They had no idea how they know what the 32 ounce of acids could have been.
Man.
It could have been.
They did that study shit to people who made some big mistakes.
Man.
People made some big mistakes.
They tried to cover it.
Yeah.
Though they tried to cover the fact that Kaczynski was a part of their,
uh,
their studies because it's a real embarrassment.
I mean,
I don't know,
when I say they,
I don't even know who the fuck they are.
I might've made that up.
How about that?
But what did happen,
what did happen is the guy became a professor of mathematics for a few years
out,
I think it was university of California Berkeley.
And he just did it to make enough money to buy this cabin in the woods and plot
his attack on technologist.
He was gone,
man.
He was gone.
This guy was out alone in the woods.
If you don't know the story of the Unabomber,
you know,
if you're a young child,
if you're coming to us under the age of 20,
you might not even have ever heard of it before.
But it was a guy who was a brilliant,
brilliant guy who was targeting all these various people that were involved in
technology and fucking blowing their heads off getting mail bomb.
Yeah.
And he was doing it all from a fucking shack in the middle of
building mailbox,
unit bottling.
Yeah.
I remember.
That's what that was like a sketch that they had of him.
And,
um,
he,
uh,
was a really terrorizing people for a long time and they were having a really
hard time figuring out who the fuck he was.
They knew he was a genius,
but they couldn't figure out who he was.
And then he released a manifesto and his brother read the manifesto and his
brother said he knew,
he said he knew right away it's like,
oh this is my crazy ass fucking psycho brother.
Lost his mind to Lsd who's living in the woods in a box.
He's got like this wooden box that he lives in,
in the middle of the woods.
He thought the technology was eventually going to a takeover and technology was
the enemy and it was a,
yeah,
there's a whole form of like anarchy.
There's a geyser.
Zahn if you look up John Zerzan,
I think his name was,
heard that name before.
Yeah.
From this intense,
like an artist.
He was like technology,
which is weird cause he's got a blog but Kosinski um,
was right in a way though,
right?
I mean technology is sort of taking over our lives and eventually it's going to
be a part of our lives permanently.
You know,
once you start going to a what does zero Zan,
I mean you,
you start getting to the point where people become human hybrids.
You know,
we,
when we become cyborgs,
you know,
technology literally will take oh yeah totally man.
I mean it's like there he saw,
I mean he saw a path and I mean it's a horrible thing that he did but it's
fascinating that blowing his brain out on acid would make them reach that
conclusion.
I mean I'm,
I might be simplifying his position.
It was a factor.
It was probably a factor.
If the guy was already imbalanced or was already off taking like heavy doses of
Harvard LSD back in,
back in the day,
that's not going to help you.
Do you think it's possible to do that to a person?
That's fine.
Do you think you could take like you that just blast your fucking brain up.
You never come back?
Fuck yeah.
Like what about Mk ultra?
The government experiments with mind control and like the idea of creating a
psychedelic bomb.
I thought you're talking about Maddy Kirsch.
No,
that's Maddie curses getting ah yeah.
Mk Ultra Man.
Look that shit up.
Yeah.
So the,
the a psychedelic bomb.
What do you mean?
Like what were they trying to do?
They're trying,
that's if you ever seen Jacob's ladder.
Yes.
That's,
yeah,
it's like that,
that it's like the idea is they were um,
uh,
they were experimenting with some kind of Psychedelic that you could drop on
troops like a nerve agent.
They would,
they would just all trip out,
fall down and trip out,
fight if you're tripping really out charge enough.
So true.
So like that it was like they were a great idea.
That is a great idea.
Yeah.
Just bonk everybody out on acid and,
sure.
Fucking love bond.
A bond.
They wanted it to explode in the air and somehow or another everybody would get
infected with acid.
I don't know how they were going to fucking distribute it.
It was probably gas.
If you would think that Lsd,
you just need a tiny amount of LSD or the,
so it's,
it was explained this shit wasn't Lsd,
Joe.
This was like new something,
something they were trying to make to give you fucked up trips to give you.
Like,
it wasn't like they wanted to give you a nice LSD trip.
This,
some of the stuff they whipped up.
Yeah,
but I mean even if it was just a strong LSD,
if you it,
if you blew it on the troops,
they'd be jacked.
Oh yeah,
that's right.
Duncan,
LSD troops,
troops.
No,
it was a big shift that they're talking about is like are they were like,
it was a bad like bad trip.
It's like a,
an evil death trip.
It's not a good trip.
And everybody would just fall down and be twitching in this trip.
Well,
but is that more humane than the new kingdom killing them?
Which is better.
That's better for sure.
Maybe Richard Bell.
It's better than new customer.
If you ever met a guy that likes bad trips,
like that was like,
that was his bondage.
Like,
I just need to worst trinkets as fetish.
Oh,
I guess I'm,
but yeah,
you know that's a real terror though.
People pretend they like terror.
Nobody
likes terror.
You pretend you like terror cause he's want to be different or dangerous or
moody or dark.
But real
Tara bad trips are now know what that bitch did I ever tell you about the time I
saw a
woman freaking out on acid at a rave?
No,
we were leaving.
It was in the morning.
It's me and my friend were leaving and this girl walks east girls like crying
and standing by herself and we went after,
I'm like,
you all right.
It can we help you.
And she's like,
I lost my friends and
I can't find them.
We're like,
okay,
well why don't we,
where did,
you know?
We're like,
we'll give you a ride home.
We'll take you home.
Um,
where do you live?
Or do you have a car here?
We're trying to help her out.
Her eyes were fucking black.
Is that as night black is the wings are silages dilated like so we're like,
so we're good.
So we're walking up the steps with her and all of a sudden she goes
is,
she's just screaming and we're like,
oh fuck,
this is a real bad trip.
She's melting down so we get to the top of the steps.
She's all of a sudden she's back to normal and she's like,
my friends,
I can't find my friends.
And I really liked it.
So we look over and there's some paramedics and we waved him down.
They get her,
put her on a table straps.
We're just strapped her down.
And the last thing I saw her was on a fucking table in front of a rave writhing
and going back into
drought.
Yeah,
they had two matches having a psychotic break.
She lost it.
She took some shit and freaked the fuck out.
And that was from acid.
I don't know.
I mean something that dilated her eyes could have been a million thing.
Don't eat the brown ass,
don't eat the brown acid,
don't eat.
That's the key.
That to me with my luck,
it feels like that's something I would have heard right after I'd eat and the
Brown.
I said,
I did take someone to just swallow it that don't eat the brown acid.
That's the problem with drugs being illegal.
You don't know what the fuck are you going to get.
Yeah.
And you don't,
and most people don't know how to take them.
No one educates people on how to take them.
So you end up with some fucking dumb,
dopey kid who slurps back too much acid or whatever at a fucking rave and ends
up in a mental asylum probably for how many people you think have gone crazy
because of acid.
Has anybody gone crazy because of anything else?
Like no one's gone crazy because at mushrooms,
right.
I don't know.
Has that ever happened?
I've never heard of that.
I think if you're borderline,
anything could definitely push you over to show over.
Easy.
Sorry.
Yeah.
Um,
I remember,
uh,
one particular DMT trip where reality was real slippery for like two weeks
afterwards where,
um,
I felt like I might be a little crazy.
I remember I felt like,
like this is a,
I've seen something that doesn't make any sense.
And Co and I got there so easy and it's so much more vibrant,
this world
that it's,
it's very difficult for me to accept this world.
So I start looking at this world as if this world might be some sort of an
artificial construct and that might be the real world.
It's a,
it sounds completely retarded until you've had a real full blown psychedelic
trip because when you have a real full blown one,
that world that you enter,
whatever the fuck that is,
that world of hallucination.
I mean hallucination is a strange word because it implies something.
You see something that's not there.
Yeah.
And I'm not necessarily sure that that's the correct way to look at it.
I think you,
you might be seeing something that is there,
but you just can't see normally.
I think that's more likely.
I don't,
I don't think,
I mean,
I think,
you know,
people see fucking,
a six foot tall rabbit then wants to take you to a,
a secret room.
Yeah.
You're probably hallucinating.
You are definitely elites.
If you're not,
you're in fucking trouble.
But
go so far that the world around you has dissolved you,
you know,
at that point in time,
this might not be imagination.
This might be another reality.
It might be something that you're just not capable of tuning into a regular
base.
See,
this is a pro.
This,
this makes me think of a problem that I think is going to happen in the future,
which is that once they figure out how to like neurally,
uh,
put video games in your mind,
people are going to start having these real big problems differentiating,
uh,
virtual reality from actual reality.
And there's going to be some serious problems up ahead.
Because I,
it's like,
imagine,
you know,
what's the new,
what's the modern warfare three they just came out like,
imagine that,
you know,
six generations of consoles and computers down the line,
right?
You know,
and it's so whatever that is,
however they taste good,
they're going to feel it.
They might have smells involved in it,
but what happens when that reality gets so good at?
You can no longer distinguish realities.
You can no longer distinguish virtual worlds,
worlds from real worlds because they're triggering the same thing in your brain.
That reality is triggering right now.
But they're doing with computers,
so it's indistinguishable.
So how do you know when you've turned off the game?
How do you know when you're not playing anymore?
This is hippy talked man.
Oh fuck.
This is what if man,
you're right,
you're right.
I don't think this is a,
what if I die?
I will admit to a million.
What else?
But this,
this seems like if you think of where a talk,
if you think of where it's Hari was back in the,
when we remember when Atari came out,
you remember that Shit,
right?
And you saw that for me it was like,
Holy Shit.
You have to consider the possibility that if this life is some sort of an
illusion that it's some sort of an everchanging illusion and that you're
constantly in a part of it.
And maybe when you have these psychedelic trips,
you wake up temporarily from the illusion,
maybe psychedelics.
So like,
like,
like that sniffing shit they give you when you get knocked.
Yeah.
Smelling Salts was,
huh?
What's going on,
right.
Yeah.
Am I,
yeah,
that's it.
Maybe that's what it is.
Yeah,
I know that's
is the work of fiction or get appears to be.
Yeah.
This is just some kind of like,
or it's just like really low down on the spectrum of awareness.
I mean it is happening,
but you're only seeing one tiny pixel of the bigger thing.
It does
many times feel like it's a work of fiction though,
doesn't it?
Yeah.
Well yeah.
Can I tell you when it really felt like a work of fiction when we flew on Air
France first fucking class to the UK,
that was for me,
it got really,
really surreal and weird when we were sitting in that lounge.
Like this was like,
I never fly first class.
Uh,
so this was the kind of first class that I'd read about.
if,
if you're out there and you've never flown Air France first class,
first of all,
um,
please stay away from me cause I don't like talking with people who haven't
flown first class Air France.
But you,
I felt corrupted in the first 30 minutes.
I was like,
Holy Shit,
this is,
this is so like different from any other flight.
It made every other first class experience I've had seem like shit seem like it
was.
Well,
you know it was really creepy.
You know what a creepy movie they did,
man,
what everybody was there was first class,
which is really nice.
Then there was business class,
which is still really nice and then there was coach,
which always sucks.
Well we got up,
the plane landed and a lady went through the aisle telling the business class
people to get out of the way and let the first class people get off the plane.
Yes.
It's like titanic shit.
Oh Shit.
Yeah,
but I've never seen anyone do it as aggressively as this lady did it.
He almost pushed a guy back.
There was a guy was trying to get through to them.
No Sir,
no,
no.
Stay there and then we all walked by.
They,
if you have a connecting flight,
there's a bond girl basically waiting in some kind of town car that picks you up
and drives you to the security checking.
You go through the security check in there.
They're basically,
they're treating you like you're a toddler.
They take you through the security check in and then you go up to this lounge.
There's this Special Air France Lounge and Paris and we're sitting there,
Robin Williams walks Robin Williams.
That's where state things seem like fiction where it's like,
oh,
okay.
Really?
I don't know him.
I didn't want to bug them.
Yeah,
we didn't say high,
but it was very weird.
Bug the fuck
I will.
I've been bugged so long I don't need to talk to him.
I was nervous,
you know?
Yeah.
I mean,
yeah,
it,
it would feel weird.
Talk talking to him and that Matt Damon Movie,
Man.
What's that?
You're awesome in that Matt Damon Movie Man.
What was it?
Yeah,
I like the photographer one.
Oh,
that was creepy as fuck.
Yeah,
he's good.
Quite one hour or so.
But yeah,
it is weird how they push people aside that they,
they want the first class people to get off first.
Like they're made everybody sit up.
Yeah.
That was disgusting.
It's disgusting.
And it's also,
that's how a lot of people have grown accustomed to living every moment of their
lives.
You realize that the wealthy have,
cause,
you know,
sometimes I'll go out to a public place with a shit load of people and I'll walk
around.
I'll be like,
man,
I fucking hate being around all these people.
This sucks.
I don't like being in big crowds.
It's annoying.
It feels weird.
And then I'll be like,
you're being negative,
man.
You got to open up more.
You shouldn't let this bother you.
But I think a lot of super wealthy people,
they're like,
they analyze that feeling like,
yeah,
we don't want to be around anyone.
We just want to be around a small groups of people sequestered from society like
us that are like,
yeah,
that's it.
And they've,
uh,
they've,
they've essentially of,
you know how like the Galapagos islands have their own species from being
separated.
Yeah.
I think like super rich people,
they're there.
They have their own species pop and they have the zone thing happening where
they don't even,
there's,
they're really separated from us.
Like they don't know.
They don't even know about you.
I bet there's some super wealthy people they don't even fucking know about
occupy Wall Street.
They don't need,
oh,
that's ridiculous.
I wouldn't be surprised.
Oh,
come on.
That's impossible.
At this point.
That's absolutely impossible.
It felt like,
to me it felt like there is a gigantic foam separation between like us and them.
You see the Berkeley Fudge now.
I did
cops with Bhutan's just shoving them into the guts of these little kids,
girls too.
Girls shoving these Bhutan's into their sides.
She's jabbing them over and over.
Then the kids are screaming,
the kids are in a crowd.
Okay.
So the kids were in the front of the crowd and they can't even go anywhere.
It was these people behind them.
So these cops are to push the crowd back.
The cops are thrusting their Bhutan's into the unlucky people that are at the
front of the law and they're little people.
Man,
a little skinny kids and these cops are fucking Jab Bhutan's.
It's really uncomfortable.
Right.
And you have really got a great story.
The thing isn't even a focus.
No,
this isn't that.
That's not it.
It's probably right.
She one of them,
many of footage people,
they're sticking mic and we'll get them doing that shit.
Yeah,
the poking him.
This isn't it.
Yeah.
They're hitting them.
Oh Shit,
I haven't seen this one is beating them.
Fuck.
Are these people
we train.
It's so crazy.
This small group of,
it's like a classic,
the screaming stopped beating students.
This small group of men has to face this gigantic yeah.
Board of unarmed people and a small group of men,
you know the immediately calf to automatically go on the defensive and I look
at them,
they have bulletproof vests on a fucking helmets and guns strapped to their side
and Bhutan's you know,
and they all have to rare riot gear with face shields and shit.
I mean they're coming at you letting you know that they're there to fight.
You know,
I mean,
look,
this is what it is.
Look,
they're wearing helmets with face shields and shit,
man.
But I liked the guy's shirt.
It's my pink shirt and this guy.
Sure.
I hate his belt though.
That guy's shirts of baton target.
You're not calling in the Barbera dude.
Get a real well why are they,
are they telling them to get off the property or why are they good question.
Yeah.
What are they doing here?
Are they scooping these people off the property?
I'm the guest.
So the checking them for lice.
Ah Ha.
Um,
I,
you know,
obviously the telling people to stand back and the people look,
if,
if there's a crowd of people,
the people at the front,
I'm going to get pushed forward,
man.
Oh Shit.
Oh
yeah.
This is dark stuff,
man.
Looking really boot to the neck.
Wow.
Fucking bastard.
He's a,
he's going shin the neck.
That's a shitty control by the way.
A good way to teach young people down.
Don't teach them Goshen.
Sean's neck on a normal person that get right up.
Stupid.
Yeah.
Try and tickling.
Let's just try it.
You're trying to hurt somebody when you go shit neck.
Unless someone else is holding them in the back as mean,
they're trying to enforce,
you know,
they're trying to like make them feel pain as they're cuffing them.
You know?
That's right.
Getting roll found really hard.
They're really rough.
Well it's not only that there
did you see him?
He was shy.
He didn't need a shove her like that.
Who are these guys?
What are these guys do afterwards?
I don't know.
These are cops man.
Huh.
We need to find out who the specifically who these people are and,
and,
and create special uh,
videos with their names and every,
and they're bad.
There's already someone needs there.
But there needs to be a website just dedicated to identifying the police at
these protests who are being violent and pressing charges against them and suing
them and making it so that it becomes financially are dangerous for the
individual to act the way that they're acting.
Cause if these cops,
if we,
if we could just get one of them,
and I'm not saying get one violently,
obviously I'm saying,
but if we can just get one legally or financially,
if one of these cops can go down like that and then all of them will start being
afraid and they won't be so,
uh,
prone to use violence like that,
that should be,
someone should be taking charge.
So this is so surreal to me that this is happening right now.
This is what a sign of the times it says,
man,
it's like watching an Alex Jones dream or sound is watching.
This is like the Shitty was talking about,
oh,
he's right.
This is what he's been,
what I always say about Alex Jones,
he's right 70% of the time,
70% of the time he's right.
This is a 30% of the crazy stuff that he's kind of makes up that I wouldn't even
say mixed up,
but he,
he just,
he gets,
he goes a little too deep on certain,
these police are,
I don't know,
because I mean,
who knows?
It's hard for me to believe that they're thinking about the new world order or
protection.
Then globalization.
Yeah.
It feels like they're just normal guys who are doing,
that's a terrible position to be in.
I mean,
imagine if you were a cop and all of a sudden they tell you this is what you
have to do it.
You have to get the hippies off the lawn.
Uh,
sir,
there's 300,000 of them.
What are you going to do?
How are you going to get them off the lawn?
Good luck,
man.
You mean what are you supposed to do?
We will.
I,
the mayor has ordered you to clear the lawn so it must clear the lawn.
You can't clear that law and man,
what if you're a cop?
What the fuck are you going to do?
You know,
the cops are obviously being sent there to keep these people from protesting or
push them off of certain areas or keep thing from entering certain places,
but at the end of the day,
you know,
they're stuck there.
There.
There's,
there's no excuse for what they're doing and there's no excuse for beating those
people.
There's no excuse for prodding those people.
They should get absolutely not be cops because they can't handle that.
If they're doing that.
You don't have to hit someone who's not hitting you,
man.
No one knows.
People were hitting back.
That's theirs.
It wasn't like they were in danger and they had to protect themselves.
They were ragdoll on people.
Man needs to be a public shaming of those guys.
Those guys.
There needs to be,
you know how I know it's also,
here's the other part though,
the fucking with the occupy movement.
All right.
There's a lot of shenanigans going on.
A lot of it is just nuts.
It's not all a bunch of people with valid points that are out there trying to
resolve the issues that we currently have a lot of is just a crazy assholes,
you know?
I mean,
it's not all activists at these fucking things.
These things are magnets for chaos.
They're magnets for various like constant patterns of behavior in humanity that
by now stereo typical patterns of behavior like hippies,
thugs,
drug dealers,
chaos.
There's homeless people.
There's a,
there's a lot going on.
I mean it's a community of people that have taken to occupying giant chunks.
All Dude,
they showed occupy everywhere was a poster that someone put up online on the
message board and I looked at it and showed all the different places where
people are protesting like,
what the fuck man?
That's when it really hit.
When you,
there's a photo,
it says occupy everywhere.
See if you could find that dude.
There's occupy us and occupy everywhere and the photos are fucking rippy dude.
When you look at all the different protests you like ever,
or has it been like this before,
right?
That's right.
Never.
It's never been like this before.
Right?
This is incredible.
Yeah.
This is a strange,
strange time and it snuck up on us.
It was so quick.
All of a sudden there's protests are everywhere and it really makes you take
into consideration like where's the,
where's the end point?
They can't win.
You know that Martin Luther,
he can't win the fucking pigs.
Doug [inaudible] talking about the happy shades.
Higgs man,
that's
the best word.
When you see some fucking fatty with a baton poke in a 17 year old girl,
there no better description for that man.
Then pig oinker piggy.
That's what that guy is.
He's a fucking disgusting fucking pig.
A useless cowardly human who has been hired by evil people to push down the
force of evolution in the universe.
And if you try to stop evolution,
you're fucked.
I don't know what's going to happen to that pig or the people I can,
but it's not going to be great.
That's,
you can't hold it back.
What's happening?
It won't work.
I think as soon as you turn cops loose on people,
cops are used to dealing with the enemy.
They're used to dealing with criminals.
They're used to behaving a certain way because out in their world,
they have to behave that way.
If you want to stay alive as a cop,
you gotta take no bullshit from any fucking purpose.
You've got to,
you know,
you got to arrest people.
You've got to deal with dangerous,
violent criminals that don't want to go to jail and know that you want to put
them in jail.
It's a fucking high pressure,
high stress job.
The person to blame is not those cops.
It sounds like they should be to blame,
but the person that blame is the person who put those cops in a position where
they're going after law abiding citizens.
That's the problem.
Because then even though those people technically are committing any crimes
other than loitering,
I mean what are they doing?
I mean isn't there a right to protest?
But I mean who knows what the latest,
I think it's the property though.
Profit.
It's just,
you know,
they're ruining the lines.
But here's the thing,
can I just,
I just want to say,
cause it couldn't be what I said,
it could be misconstrued.
I'm not saying all cops are probably,
no you're not.
Okay then I want,
of course they're talking married.
What I'm saying is cops are wired to deal with criminals.
I mean,
they try to work with people all day,
but you gotta be on Edge,
man.
You've got to be on edge all the time.
And when some asshole tells these cops now you have to go and you have to push
back these crowds of unhappy,
intelligent people who are nonviolent.
And these people are very valid points about the corruption that is a road at
our system too.
It almost unfixable point and were fucking upset because they're in college and
where the fuck is their future?
Yeah.
Can't have ruined the whole batch.
There's nothing left for us.
We're growing up and were coming out and there's nothing left for us.
You fuck heads,
you've ruined the whole thing and you're a cop man,
and you are the enemy.
You will represent the man.
They treat you hostily you treat them Hossley.
They don't listen to you.
You treat them like criminals.
That's how you're wired.
You're wired to treat criminals like criminals.
Yeah.
They all of a sudden these young kids who are very valid points become
criminals,
but it's awesome because there's a lot of douchebags in those groups.
Those groups.
It never pure,
you know?
Well,
no.
And also those groups,
by the way,
and the whole fucking problem with the,
uh,
the current formation of this protest movement or this revolution are right now
is that it's,
it's so loosely,
uh,
what's the problem?
It's,
what's awesome about it is that it's a modular and it seems to be,
you know,
broken up in all these groups that have come together into this one thing,
but there is no easier group to infiltrate than a group like that.
So by now,
the CIA,
they there,
they must have infiltrated the,
they've got people there,
they're like,
they're studying like,
okay,
what's the best way to handle this?
How can we implement this,
break this up or make it so you guys are fuck guys.
Girlfriends.
Yeah,
I'd stick.
Fuck your girlfriend.
CIA guys just going to get,
they're going to give him my,
I grow and get these chicks high and just fuck the shit out of them.
Yeah.
These girls,
they never been with a real man.
They're hanging out with all these hips.
Oh wait.
So you think CIA fuck agents have infiltrated occupy Wall Street,
that porn movie.
That's the movie then that is the movie.
CIA porn operatives,
Cia,
Dick,
sling and experts.
Like they show up at gang bangs.
Mr. Johnson come with me.
You're government needs you.
And he said,
man,
I'm in the middle of fucking all these bitches and this guy's just banging these
bitches left and right.
And that's what they do.
They sell them as a group of them in one of the guys,
they got to pull out a retirement.
They're like,
I can't fuck again.
My soul out in Vietnam.
I'm not going.
We need you.
You've got to come.
These hippie girls have got to be fucking hippie girls with not getting good
dick ever.
These guys are eating nothing but granola and hemp seeds and shit.
And they smell.
They just,
no one's just grammar these fucking the shit out of him.
And that's what the CIA guys do.
These,
these poor guys,
they send them in,
they start fucking all these girls.
It will creates turmoil.
It's a special division.
It's like the 18 and they had their be fuckers.
Yeah.
They call themselves the Hippie fucker.
Yeah,
they've been doing,
if there's boot camps where they still imagine that would work,
man.
On a lot of these unfucking balanced people that would work.
Fuck them into submission.
Send,
send a bunch of guys to just go in there and fuck everyone,
man.
Well I guess going to hire like Brad Pitt looking dudes.
Yeah,
just have them just run through the ranks,
get in with them,
get tight with them and then just start banging dude's wives.
That's your job.
And then like be real sloppy about it,
you know,
to say that you want to be dangerous but get caught,
get caught left and right all the time.
All the time.
Everybody gets caught.
Everybody gets called [inaudible] slow to leave loads all of the bed you pull
out on Tom Purpose and shoot your load.
Every park cushion,
you know the guy sits down and looks at it.
He's like,
this is a fucking load.
You've been fucked by the CIA.
CIA has infiltrated our tents so they have like,
they actually can come in a pattern that indicates they were there.
Yeah,
that's what they do.
They come on you and then they let it slowly congeal and then they put a seal on
it.
So they brand you.
I gotta use the bathroom.
Go use the bathroom,
man.
Don't hold it in Jesus Christ.
You know where it is in our powerful new desk.
Quad studios do two,
two,
two.
So Brian,
do you know anything about you don't know anything about this football case.
Dot.
Can we go on?
So over there you don't know where you're going.
Fucking guy gets lost in a room with two
doors.
I know he tried that already.
Do you need know anything about this football case?
Uh,
now we talked about it or on one of the podcasts earlier,
but I it,
it seems like one guy who was caught up to 40 different people that he's fucked
again,
showers and stuff.
And he was a assistant football coach and Dusky and he apparently,
it's like a famous guy.
I don't know anything about the world of football,
but I've heard the name Joe Paterno.
Yeah,
I've heard the name.
And then I guess a Ashton Kutcher,
uh,
came on Twitter and said something like,
I can't believe they fired him or something like that.
Like he was defending the guy and then somebody said that he now he asked him,
gave,
is his Twitter account to somebody else to do for now on,
because it's just too many feedback from what he said or so someone else's
handling his Twitter
that says he complained that the fire,
the guy who covered up a fucking assistant coach was banging kids.
Let me tell you something,
man.
If a guy's bang and kids,
you kind of know,
right?
I don't think you don't know,
especially for 40 accurate guys taking kids on the road with him.
Right.
He took kids on the road and put them up in hotels,
bought them presence and shit.
You know,
and not only that,
there was a story that the da who was investigating the case disappeared in 2005
so,
you know,
they had to fire a man.
This could be some crazy cover up murder shit.
We don't even know what the fuck happened yet.
This guy was like a loved guy.
I mean,
this is a huge,
huge scandal.
Apparently.
You know,
I talked to people that were,
what does it,
Penn state,
is that what it is?
Yep.
Nittany lions.
Is that what they call themselves?
I don't even know him.
I'm sorry.
People like you don't know shit about football.
You fucking push.
Hey,
here's the mountains.
Here's what a missing guy.
I listened.
Desky guy.
Yeah,
he's a missing Da.
The district attorney,
he went missing in 2005,
eight fucking probably ice.
This guy,
man,
you know when you're dealing with a case this big,
apparently what happened was a grad student went into a shower,
went back to retrieve something and he heard noises in the shower that were
like,
like steady,
rhythmic slapping noise is went in and saw this guy fucking an eight,
a 10 year old boy in the ass in the shower.
And they are also investigators have him on the phone with one of the boys,
mothers.
And the boy's mother asks him if he touched the boy in an inappropriate place,
in an inappropriate manner.
And he goes,
uh,
maybe,
maybe he said maybe.
Yeah.
It was like,
yeah.
Um,
I don't know.
Maybe.
Maybe I did.
You maybe you did like it when you're that crazy,
you're that pedal.
They were protecting a pedo man.
That's,
that's all this is because they don't want to run the football.
They were crazy straight up protecting a pedo.
There's no question about it.
There's no question about it,
man.
You know that
this is no way you can hide that darkness,
man.
That's as dark as it gets.
Your fucking little boys in her little assholes.
You're going to hide that 10 year old boys,
not even a man.
You know,
it's not,
it's not like you're tricking men and,
uh,
in your bank and you know,
pour straight man.
No,
no,
no.
You're,
you're banging a little bit boys.
You're appeasers Shit,
man.
Worse than your worst than the worst kind of demon.
Yeah.
How does,
how does,
how is it possible that that guy can just be interacting with everyone else and
they're not going to know that no one's going to weird out.
You're all going on the road together and know there's a Mr Sandusky.
What is his fucking 10 year old buddy?
You'd be like,
what are you doing with this 10 year old boy?
Is this your son?
If that was your son,
that's one thing.
Well he's close to his kid.
He likes to take his kid with him when he goes to football games.
Little boy loves football.
Yeah.
Okay,
that's great.
That's a great dad.
But if you're a guy and he's just taking some 10 year old around with you and
he's always got new presence and shit.
How does everybody not look at that?
How does everybody not go?
What the fuck is going on with this guy?
There's something,
there has to be some weird interaction between them.
There has to be something that treats you that there has to be when a little a
boy's getting fucked by some old man you don't,
you don't just sneak that through.
It was a 10 year old boy.
I Dunno,
he's always near me.
Where kid.
No,
but there's like,
you know,
in families,
kids,
people who have been molested.
It was like pre,
they would pretend that it was a happening.
The family would kind of pretend it wasn't there,
but they all know it's kind of there but nobody wants to deal with it cause it's
so fucked up.
I know a girl who was molested by her uncle and her family attacked her and her
sister and her cousins who are all molested by the same guy.
Her family all attack them and said that there were all lying and they're like,
whoa.
Like this guy molested them for years,
for years and nobody would believe it.
That's it.
It's amazing.
They were,
what if they go and ask the family on the list of the uncle and that was like
their little gangs and they're just trying to cover their evil 10 year old
demons going out to the uncles.
Yeah.
You read that book,
Lolita?
No,
it's really good.
I said
no,
it's what gave birth to that term.
I know it's really bizarre man.
The arbitrary age of 18 when one,
when one becomes legal,
because there was a thread on the message board recently where some attractive
young lass has just become 18 and there was a celebration.
So it was all these photos of this a well endowed little hooker and I shouldn't
call her hooker.
She's probably a nice girl.
Well endowed little night.
When I say hooker I call my friends hookers.
Yeah,
like I'll call it Dunkin Hooker.
I don't mean in a bad way just to clarify,
but as well endowed nice young lady and they're all talking about fucking the
shit out of her.
And I'm like,
man that's dark.
She was just a little baby like a couple of weeks ago,
like a couple of weeks ago,
she was 17 and now she's 18 and you guys all want to shove your rods inside of
her.
Like that's dark man,
isn't it?
It's Kinda dark.
There's something,
but it's fucking totally legal.
You know this one guy was like,
I'd like to see or dirty condor solved over.
You're saying some like really Ruthie Shit cunt.
I'll fuck the shit out of this dirty con.
Something along those lines and it made me laugh because it was ridiculous cause
it was so over the top.
But then I thought about,
I'm like,
it's kind of creepy that you can say this about an 18 year old where you cannot
say that about a 16 year old Europe
piece of Shit,
man.
Yeah.
What about states that are even younger?
Like 15 and stuff,
right?
Like other 14 before and that's crazy.
Yeah.
Well you know,
I think,
I don't think it's uniform all across the country.
I think Nevada where that fucking dude,
that 51 year old dude got
married.
Damn he's neighbor Sam Tripoli's name,
but we didn't get to talk about it on Sandra.
Forgot.
We forgot to talk about neighbors as Courtney Stotten a we'll talk about it on
tonight.
Spark Cassandra please.
Oh,
beautiful.
Yeah.
We're going to do another podcast tonight,
folks.
This is how fucking wild we are.
We're doing a podcast was Dunkin were Dunkin.
Okay.
Talk.
We're doing a podcast with Dunkin.
And then when we're done with this,
we've got a show tonight,
a sold out show at the Ice House in Pasadena on stage to the intimate venue.
And so we're going to do that afterwards and we're all going to come back here
and do podcasts in between our sets.
So it's uh,
this fucking new room is key.
This is awesome.
It's such a sweet set up.
It's at the Ice House.
So we're going to be doing a lot more podcasts from here.
But what were we just talking about?
We're talking about fucking Courtney style.
Yeah.
And she's,
she's Tripoli's neighbor man.
Well let triply talk about it again today.
It's a teaser,
ladies and gentleman.
But in the meantime,
before it,
before Tripoli comes on,
immediately follow Courtney Stotten on Twitter,
then let the triple he fill in the rest of the batch or Twitter's ridiculous.
And she's 16 going on 40.
She looks like a 38 year old ladies here on doc herself.
Dr Drew,
I had her on there just to see it cause everyone says her boobs are fake.
Right?
So they had this doctor come in there and they made this whole like episode with
like trying to figure out if it's boobs are real and like the doctors had a hard
time like I can't see through this muscle.
It's like they really built it up even the whole time.
They're just feeling her tits and she just didn't exist so crazy.
They're feeling 16 year and Mexican guys where that was such a repress culture.
We're such as sexually repressed culture that this kind of shit is what we
fixate on.
This is why we fixate on this is a real thing.
Oh yes.
Bring her in.
Bringing the sluts so we can test her breasts.
Well,
it's not like they don't like each other.
They obviously enjoy each other's company.
The hang around together.
I mean it was just,
you're not supposed to be banging a 16 year old dude.
No.
And check this out.
The,
I guess the photographer of a lot of her photos,
her sexy photos,
like where she is with her,
her boyfriend or husband,
whatever are actually taken by her mom.
Mom.
Yeah.
Did you ever see there was like a one of those 2020 type shows and it was all on
this porn star whose parents support her work?
What?
What was her name?
I'm trying to remember it that it's the one that uh,
that bunny ranch guy used to hang out with.
It's not sunny.
Is it?
Low noise.
So on the wane Sunnyville Wayne,
sunny,
Sunny Leone sending you Leone,
is that it?
No,
I don't think that is,
isn't it hurt?
I think that's a different girl.
I think it's really fucking weird.
And that's a dark haired girl,
I think.
Don't you think it's really fucking weird?
And,
and I,
and I think it's like obviously completely fucked up to like,
uh,
fuck people under 18.
But in general,
don't you think that outside of that,
which I think is like sociologically,
it's super fucked up and it clearly fucks people's lives up and people would do,
it should be thrown alligators.
But in general,
isn't it strange that for adults,
sex,
the terms used to describe sex,
dirty,
naughty,
filthy.
It's like we attached to the act of bringing life into the universe or
simulating bringing life into the universe.
We attached to that so many adjectives that are just like,
it's disgusting.
Smut,
filth.
That's what,
when you look at porn,
that's like the words they use to sell porn,
the dirtiest smmody as filthiest whores,
this side.
It's like,
yeah.
It's so strange that
because of obviously,
because in order to have an industrial revolution in order to,
you know,
have a,
the society that we currently enjoy,
people who have to work and if people would just dirty fucking all day,
they would complicate shit.
Nothing would ever get done.
We have an ethic and one of the ethics is you keep your fucking sexuality to
yourself all day long.
Very weird.
Mr. Herman Cain with your fucking unwanted massages.
Fucking,
yeah.
Yeah.
It's,
it's so fucking strange,
man.
It's like,
yeah,
it's,
you were telling me about how you were in,
what did you say you were in Germany and you watch like a gang bang on regular
TV.
They didn't show penetration,
but this dude was banging.
This chick from behind her tits are flopping around.
There was other people behind them.
They were fucking,
yeah.
It was like,
it was almost like some software
core sort of a thing.
But what you said about Hartman at this strip club,
that's,
to me that's like,
that's how it should be.
It should be joyful.
It converts.
It's like it's the fact that it's not,
is an indication of how like backwards and repress we are.
Yeah.
I mean,
by the way,
you know,
filthy dirty things are awesome.
I'm not saying that that doesn't add to like the excitement of it,
but it seems like in,
in our culture it's so,
it's so like fucking scarlet letter,
Nathaniel Hawthorne style humiliation of people who really aren't doing anything
that bad compared to what other people in the world,
they're doing it right.
You know,
like it's,
it's a,
it's a lot worse for,
you know,
we probably talked about this
because we,
we have the instinct to fuck more than his mesentery.
We,
we,
we have the instinct to fuck like we needed to fuck 10,000 years ago and half
the babies were eaten by crocodiles.
You know,
we have this,
this drive,
as long as the man is alive,
as long as the man,
his breathing healthy and Phil and robust,
they want to fuck,
they want to shoot loads and the people and create more.
And it's just,
it's just the desire to breathe.
That's all it is.
The desire to breed manifest itself in a code that's in,
that runs your body.
And as long as that code runs your body,
people are gonna want to fuck.
And if that's going to be the case,
people go,
there's no way going to get anything done because people were just going to be
trying to fuck each other all day.
Cause that's what they wanna do.
So you have to figure out a way to suppress them and control them and to calm
them down.
Peto bear cuddle,
bear approval.
You,
you know,
to calm them down to the point where you know,
things get done.
So you have to tell them it's naughty,
it's dirty topic.
Just to put it away,
put her away.
You got to shame him.
It's the only way they feel bad about pulling it out.
Oh,
I don't want to fuck her,
but I can't heal.
You go in the bathroom and taking the other girl you're working with
because you have this massive suppression during the day of your natural
instincts and feelings.
You can express them.
Didn't Mckenna talk about some primordial like World War II?
There were my,
sure more Jesus like this.
People can buy shrimp.
Utopian view of the past was that there was a,
at one point in time,
society had engaged in like almost daily mushroom use and that's what an
elevated us from the lower hominids and that was the whole stoned ape theory.
He believes that psychedelic mushrooms and the eating of them was responsible
for the doubling of the human brain size over affiliate period of 2 million
years.
Huge,
huge mystery in the fossil record.
So he had a lot of like a really nutty theories like that.
But you know,
they're very interesting to consider.
But I don't know,
given an orgy.
No,
no.
Never ever been an orgy.
Brian,
just two girls.
I will foul.
I've never been in,
Hello Columbus,
Ohio.
I know.
I know people who've been to orgies.
I was at a party that I know a girl worked at a place where they would have
orgies.
She worked as a cocktail waitress at this place where they would go.
People would go and then they would just start fucking,
they would just meet up and go into rooms and fucking everywhere she went.
She like,
people were just fucking everywhere you went,
you got there and they weren't pretty,
they weren't good looking people,
but they were just all of them like naked,
half naked,
somewhere dressed.
Some,
some didn't participate.
They just watched and there was like a club in La and people would go and just
fuck.
Yeah,
it was crazy.
She was like laughing at it.
She's like,
it is the weirdest job.
She goes,
after a couple of hours,
I got used to the fact that people were just all around and fucking all the time
and nobody bothered me.
She's like this.
The one thing that happens,
you know when everyone else is fucking,
and someone who wants to serve you drinks,
he barely even concentrate on that person.
You're like,
Yay,
here's your money.
Thank you.
Bye.
I'm gonna go fuck somebody wants to fuck me.
So it was like much safer actually than working at a bar where you were looked
at as like,
oh look at this girl.
Come in with,
what are you going after?
Who Do you do what you live with me.
You know those,
those guys didn't even look at her.
Cause there's all these people that were fucking in front of them.
Everyone was sucking cock and everyone,
you could bang anybody,
you know.
So there's a probably a few contrarians.
They're like turn their gaze towards her.
Like fuck all these people that are banging each other.
What about this girl?
How she feels about this?
And they always get to have that one.
The one girl,
he doesn't want to fuck it.
Who you fall in love
with.
Just some dudes that are just broken.
There's some dudes that are broken.
They always go for the girl that's going to just be damaged goods and always
going to need,
need to be with the person who can't be with them.
Yeah.
It's always the case.
We need the grand distraction,
the grand distraction of relationships.
You know I'm ever imagined when you were young.
I remember when you were young,
rather imagine if you felt like that now,
like when you were young and you'd break up,
you really would think like,
God,
this is the end.
I can never,
I can never be happy in a relationship again.
You used to believe that.
Yeah,
sure.
14 how many songs are about that?
There's the catalyst songs that that's the main message is that it's over.
I have no earthly songs like begging for one more night.
Yeah.
Give me just one.
It's so gross.
So Beta and so bait.
Don't you got a Rolodex Homie?
Don't you got other girls you can call them.
This is some planet of the ape shit son.
Let me just give you a little heads up.
You need to go to the gym and do some squats,
eat some bison meat and get your shit together son and get some,
get some street stopped doing that.
Brian,
get some strong game and your system,
something that's been murdered that live the free life,
wild life,
and then you shoot it with a fucking bow and Arrow and then you take that thing
and cut it up and eat it.
That's what you need to do.
And squats and carry logs up hills.
We don't need to do,
do you mean just,
yeah,
that's what girls go wet for.
Begging,
bagging.
Ah.
Just going to keep them around and be nice to him.
Fuck the shit out of them.
The end,
they leave,
they leave.
He'd go,
Hey,
you know I did my best.
I was nice to you.
I fucked the shit out of you.
Obviously you've got issues.
What about this?
Remember this.
Then met miles go,
should we store?
He sounds,
it burned into my mind if you ever heard that,
but can you imagine if that wasn't even a real song?
But it was like a song that occurs in his dream world.
It's Dan Fogelberg,
Cesar divorce.
These are divorced songs.
These are,
there was,
there was a divorce boom.
And during this divorce,
boom,
this specific genre of music came out.
And I know it very well cause that's what my mom listened to.
She come and pick me up at the Y and I would sit in the backseat of her car.
She listened to like turn around,
bright eyes fall apart.
That's a divorce song.
And she would cook.
She would get,
you know,
it's very like dramatic and those songs are burned into my mind.
And one of them was that Dan Fogelberg song.
Oh My,
here's my,
my experience
with Dan Fogelberg when I was growing up,
I lived in San Francisco when I was about from seven to 11 and uh,
we had a next door neighbor who was cool guy named Barry and uh,
who's,
uh,
my Stepdad's a buddy and we would go over place and listen to his records
and they had some bad ass records.
Is San Francisco in the 70s.
Man,
he had the monkeys and all this shit.
And I just loved the fact that you could put a headphone on and it pushed it,
pushed it to the Jack and you play a record.
And it was like,
you know,
it was in your head.
I'd be singing along,
they'd have to tell me to shut up,
stop singing and you sick.
Terrible.
But,
uh,
I remember thinking like,
wow,
you know,
uh,
my parents listen to some cool ass fucking music.
You know,
there's some cool music.
Like I listened to some Billy Joel,
you know,
I remember listening to the Captain Jack when I was like seven years old,
don't know what a great fucking song this is.
God Damn.
And then,
uh,
we had a friend and I was over his house and I asked him if I could listen to
his music and he said,
yeah.
And he had a Dan Fogelberg record and I put that shit on.
And I was like,
why does this guy wanted to press me?
Like,
so is this man,
why is this guy singing this?
What is he saying?
You're making me cry,
man.
I'm fucking seven years old.
You're bumming me out.
You know,
or whoever I was when I read,
listen to that.
But I was like,
this is just nonsense music.
Oh,
poor guy.
Somebody needs to tell him.
But then you know,
the thing is,
this is where people get confused.
That one guy,
James Taylor did it,
right?
Yeah.
And that's why everybody gets fucked up because he had songs that were like
super emotional and everything,
but they,
they had such a point of view that they were special.
There was something to do,
the shit that he was singing.
So even though it was,
it was,
it seemed like it was kind of Mushy,
but in fact it wasn't what it was was just vulnerable and honest.
And there's like a strength in that.
Yeah,
totally.
You know?
And so these,
these other motherfuckers,
well,
whenever you hate a music,
whenever you hear in a song,
make it through the night.
That was something that still confuses me.
What does that mean?
Can we can,
we can make it through the night.
Do you like,
well,
how do you not make it through the night from fucking,
you're not going to die fucking what's the,
what's the worry when people seeing making it through the night,
what is it make an out there that night?
No,
no,
this,
it's like there's no,
it's always sad when they're singing it.
Like they're going,
going to war or something,
you know,
make it,
make it anything.
They mean like getting,
going through trenches are like not having a nervous breakdown that writers,
no,
it's like what it is.
When you listened to a certain songs and you,
you,
you hear people getting all emotional and you don't feel like it's,
you don't feel like it's valid.
It's like you're being too much of a pussy in this song.
Oh,
you're being put too much of a pussy with your expression.
I could go along with you here.
I can get caught up in the wave and go with you,
but I don't feel like it's necessary.
I don't feel like it warrants it,
you know?
Then you listen to like James Taylor and you hear like just yesterday morning
they met me know you will go.
Yeah,
of course.
A depressing fucking song.
I seen fire and ice and rain since sunny days I thought would never end.
Or Elliot Smith who was an Elliot Smith,
same.
He would know like Rogan,
Rogan one I don't think would like Elliot Smith at all.
Yeah,
I listened to some of his stuff.
I wanted to kick him in the balls.
I was like,
kid,
you need to get out of the house,
stop playing video games.
I will listen to one song because Duncan told me how great the guy was.
Like wow,
there's a lot of shit that I love that I'm sure you don't love.
You know Elliot Smith.
Um,
do you have a listen to kiss alone in your car and say along nope.
Black keys all the way back.
He got a lot of black lives.
That's awesome.
They're great.
I went on a period for like four months,
so that's all I listen to.
Yeah.
I would go on my car and I got the iPod thing in the car and I would just go
right to black keys.
Yeah.
You know what I've been listening to lately.
What you'll make fun of me spangle to [inaudible].
This is one,
he did a spangle a thing where they took their music and they combined it with
me talking about DMT.
That's cool.
Yeah it's pretty dope.
Songs are tripping man.
One of the songs I was just listening to down and write,
I like writing and listening to him.
One of his songs I was hearing today the lyrics are like Lsd DMT
and it's like if you heard that song it's really,
we are,
I'm,
I mean I can't even sing it cause you have to have like seven synthesizers in a
Ufo just to make fucking noises are coming out of here.
Devon Ufo like rave music.
Right.
Is that what you would consider raving and kind of like ambient rave music or
something?
It's,
but yeah,
some of it's,
yeah,
it's not,
it doesn't have like as much of a driving beat.
It's just more like super trippy psych.
The guy really did capture
something and brought it back through music.
He's,
it's w he's really good.
It's really good.
It's not like I've listened to some of that stuff that's not so focused,
not so tuned in.
It's really kind of gross.
Yeah.
I can't,
it's like everything else,
man.
It's like mushy song.
It's like what we just talked about James Taylor and he's not mushy.
Right.
You know?
But like there's certain we meet not,
there's not Moshi,
his genuine,
there's certain people like they get really offended by non genuine behavior.
Yeah.
Like there's some huge push to get Nickelback [inaudible] moved from,
what is it a hockey game?
Is it,
is it hockey?
The Nickelback thing?
Uh,
I can't remember.
I think so.
It might be football.
I saw this thing on reddit and I,
maybe I don't,
I'm not remembering it right.
But it said,
if you ever want to hide files on your computer,
right folder that says Nicole.
That's hilarious.
I met the dude very briefly,
the lead singer guy in a,
um,
uh,
a venue once where the UFC was going to be there on Saturday and he was there on
Friday.
Friday was very nice guy as lions Thanksgiving game protest for Nickelback.
He's got,
they got some good songs,
man.
I'm sorry.
They say they're slick,
they're overproduced.
It seems like they're,
you know,
almost people like them because they're too good a pop song,
you know?
And sometimes they're like,
uh,
the,
you know,
it's almost too cliche,
but they're good that I want to be a rock star Song.
This has been a million of those,
the Cypress Hill
version.
So you'd want to be a rockstar.
That's the best one.
I ended up at the bar.
I got to admit,
man,
I've got very,
very limited.
Yeah.
Cypress Hill version is bad out I Cypress Hill,
but that's a bad ass rock star Song.
But the Nickelback one is not bad,
man.
It's not,
it's not a bad song.
I ever heard that song.
I want to be a rock style.
Go.
I'm sorry.
Really?
Well,
I don't,
I don't hate Nickelback.
Okay.
I don't particularly look forward to listening to them,
but they got some good songs.
They're not,
that's like his voice or the style of their music.
Just like chalk seems almost,
it seems like people feel like it's not honest or something,
you know?
W what is it?
I mean,
is it,
well,
there are affected.
It's affected their videos.
I think I've seen a Nickelback video and it was very effective effected and it
was very,
uh,
um,
hard to watch because it was sappy and like cheese.
Super cheesy.
But yeah,
I like,
I,
I don't have a strong opinion about them.
They also seem like,
you know,
there's certain bands like,
remember when new kids on the block came out and it was like kind of hip to not
like new kids on the block.
It's like,
they're kind of like that where it's a mark of the,
it's like a fashion to not like them or something.
Yeah.
I'm,
they've got some good stripper song.
I've never listened to that.
I don't know.
I've only listened to dean that one.
How could it be worse than some of foreigner songs?
I've been waiting for a girl like you food.
I like that
it's a good song.
But come on man.
How is,
how are any of the Nickelback songs any less sad?
Yeah,
I believe that first.
I believe that guy.
I don't believe this.
Nickelback I think this guy's just like
sincere.
So you think it gets packaged pre produced,
Cook is frail Yo later thought out to to calculated.
Is that what it is?
What do you think that guy like?
I think radio killed Nickelback for me,
I think it's,
I believe
radio from,
it's interesting with this subject because we talked about a real band.
I mean as real and scratchy as you can get.
The black keys,
they're like scratchy.
They're like almost like,
even though it's an MP three like you could hear the record,
you know those guys are like that.
That's a band man.
There's a band playing instruments and singing and these are some songs they
wrote and this is the sounds they like.
And if you're drinking whiskey and playing pool,
that's the fucking song you want to hear.
You want to hear that shit in the background.
You know they got,
that's real music man.
And then you've got,
you know,
other stuff like Nickelback that's like this.
This is a sort of a different thing.
It's like they just got it honed down to like the slick Lee packaged sort of,
kind of cliche and it's intense but very well done.
Like you can't criticize any aspects,
so it's very well gone.
That's this.
The voice is strong and the sing the guitars good,
but somehow or another,
some for some people the,
they get upset by it.
Well,
some people,
it's really weird man.
Some people just,
they're,
they're rubber ain't touching the road when it comes to what they're making.
They're
just,
they're purely imitative,
right?
Some people have like plugged into the fucking,
uh,
magma and they're vomiting out this thing.
They're like,
they've become a channel to something and it's undeniable when you hear it,
even if you don't like it,
you can still tell.
This is definitely a real,
most of the time you can still tell this is,
this is something super unique and special.
It's very,
to me,
it's funny when you see imitators,
it's funny when you,
cause you can't fake it.
It's one thing you can't fucking fake.
It's like what Joey Diaz says.
I don't know if he still says there.
It says it all the time.
Holograms ever heard him say that they're holograms.
Yeah.
He says that about people that are fake.
He's a fucking Hologram.
Yeah.
It's interesting.
You can't really fake it.
And when you see like [inaudible] but with some artists they really plug into
it.
Like that fucking kid I was telling you about.
Yes.
Yeah,
I think he's,
yeah,
nine or two.
I think he's not,
well this is,
I think he's 12 wow.
Yeah.
Well I think the,
the,
it's all going through the Internet apparently.
There was like a big piece on him from my 2006 and now he's been like studying
and,
and
Europe looks this whole time.
But yeah,
you told me about him and then after you told me about them,
it was all over Twitter,
all over my message board.
There was like a couple of different threads about it.
You know,
it just,
it's a
meme,
you know about this kid.
You saw this thing or this kid.
He's like,
they say super genius to get super genius musician.
He's like the greatest musician to come along.
Oh,
is he that movie based off of him?
No,
no,
no.
This is a new kid.
And tell him when he does.
This is crazy.
He,
the one of this segment I saw,
it's,
I'm sure if you youtube this kid you can find it right away,
but he,
he,
he's with his piano teacher and he takes the music and he flips it backwards and
upside down and he can play it backwards.
He can play music backwards and upside down too.
That's what she,
and she was like,
I don't see how he al,
anyone can do this.
He's composed like five symphonies and they say that most people don't do that
or do that in their lifetime.
Wrap your head around that.
Wrap your head around that kid.
What is that?
Is it a mild form of autism
matrix?
He tapped.
That's not him.
How does he do that?
We'll get this skill involved.
The,
I don't understand.
We're looking at a little boy who was literally looking at the keyboard.
It's amazing.
He has his back to the piano.
Listen to the music.
He's a prodigy.
What if we get so dumb that this is what is considered?
It's a super chimp.
Gradguru.
Have you had a champion?
I can do that.
Not only can my chimp do this.
Joe,
did you hear,
why don't you all find that video as I'm trying to do what is a what?
What would you think the problem is?
I can't remember
name.
So you'd have to look up like Ah,
12 year old girl.
She's super genius musician.
Yeah,
and he pretty much says what all super genius guys say is that it just comes
down.
He says he hears it,
he just hears it and he writes down what he hears.
That's what it is.
Wow.
Oh,
how the fuck did he do it backwards?
That's amazing.
That's just showing off the little fuck.
Yeah.
You know the pro,
I don't think,
I don't know if this is him.
What is it?
That's actually
Brian,
did you put butthole and the suits search?
Hey,
let's butthole in a search.
Really?
I don't understand.
It seems like that waste time.
Yeah,
that's Brian always Google searches.
He adds buttholes.
That's,
that's definitely,
definitely not.
I am Brian.
Find it.
Brian.
That was listed under an amazing 10 year old,
12 year old.
I know.
That's what happened to be super genius musician and it's not going Juilliard
host.
How many?
What did you do?
Five symphonies,
right?
Come bright 12 year old composed five symphonies.
Put that in Google and you'll find it will tweet to us.
Yeah,
they probably already have,
but if you just Google 12 year old composed five symphonies for sure you'll find
that.
Got It.
Yeah.
See that's a blue Jay.
Just renowned Julliard school who some say is the greatest talent to come along
in 200 years.
What was written?
I'm saying that about you.
Listen to this
oh shit.
What happened?
It was just the commercial.
There's a composer studying at New York's where now and Judah,
who some say is the greatest talent to come along into
so on and sand sands.
Sam Zeeman is a composer.
He teaches music theory to Jay at Julliard in New York City where he's been
teaching for 17 years.
Mel Levine's,
this is an absolute fact.
This is objective.
This is not a subjective opinion.
They could be sitting right here and he could be composing right now.
She could finish a piano sonata before our very eyes in probably 25 minutes and
it will be a great piece.
How's that possible?
Well,
Jay told us he doesn't know where the music comes from,
but it comes fully written,
playing like an orchestra in his head.
As you hear it playing,
can you change it as it goes along?
Can you say your cell phone?
Let's bring the oboes and here let's bring the string section here
to come in by themselves if they need to.
It's not something you're trying to do.
It's like the unconscious mind is giving orders at the speed of light.
You know?
I mean,
so I just hear it as if it were a smooth performance of a work already written
when it isn't.
It's involuntary.
Oh,
so yeah,
like the beating of the heart.
You don't have to think about it
[inaudible]
like it seems all the kids are downloading music these days.
It's just that Jay with his program is downloading it from his mind.
The program records his notes and plays them back.
That is where the computers up and running.
J composes so rapidly that he often crashes the computer.
It is.
It isn't a book.
You got a picture of the score,
the better get them a better teacher.
It's a project.
Give them a Mac book.
Jason parents are as surprised as anyone.
One neither is a professional musician.
His father,
Robert is a linguist to scholar in Slavic language who lost his sight at the age
of 36 to retinitis Pigmentosa is mother or no,
isn't Israeli born painter?
That's Michael Jay's eight year old brother.
He's not a musical prodigy,
but Robert and or no,
remember when they figured out that Jay was
I think around two.
So one of the Penn state kids writing,
whoa.
Look at that.
Back to the drawing instruments.
We know that he was fascinated with it.
Started writing.
Yeah.
At the age of two.
Yes.
So looking man and just see what you brought it to the same channel and wrote
the word cello.
And I was surprised because neither of us have anything to do with stringed
instruments.
Um,
and I didn't expect him to know what it was,
what a cello was.
Right.
You didn't have a cello that we had no channel your house.
Have you seen a cello?
Nope,
but he knew he wanted one.
So his mother brought him to a music store where he was shown a miniature cello
and he just sat there.
He put the cello and he started playing on it.
And I was like,
how do you know how to do this
by age three?
Schiele drawing cellos.
But he had turned them into notes on a scale,
reincarnate beginning to compose.
Wow.
Jay's parents watched the notes come faster and faster.
He was writing any time,
anywhere by elementary school.
His teachers had no idea how to handle a boy whose hero wasn't Batman,
but Beethoven.
He hears music in his head all the time.
That's awesome.
Jay has been told his hearing is many times more sensitive than an average
person.
The sound is shut out manually,
but Jay can't turn off the music in his head.
In fact,
yeah,
he told us he often,
yes.
Here's more than one new composition at a time.
Multiple channels is what has been termed multiple channels.
My brain is able to control two or three different musics at the same time.
Whoa.
Along with the channel of everyday life and everything else.
J channel this piece,
when he was eight,
by the age of 10,
Jay was going to Julliard among the top conservatories of music on a full
scholarship,
considered imitation,
um,
an extra concrete objects line.
At age 11,
he was studying music massive.
That was your kid,
your college,
you know,
like I'm a fucking idiot.
Jl Genius for horses at another school,
which is Karen say he'll complete when he's 14 completely and stay with
Elizabeth Wolf is a well known as a concert pianist who works with Jay on his
piano technique.
One more today.
Jay brought one of his own works to practice.
Yeah.
You need this
no choice.
Right.
Jay writes things that he can't even play.
Jesus fucking Christ.
It's the experience.
Phoenix is this good?
Keep up
to Canon.
It's a few,
Huh?
Jenny wants to perfect his piano playing.
Although he says he doesn't need the piano or any instrument to compose.
When you first hear this tune start to rise in your head,
what happens?
Well at first they just listened to it.
Um,
and then I started humming it and then when walking,
I like walking a lot when I'm in,
when I'm inspired
because then I walked to the beat of the,
yeah.
Music.
Sorry.
Exam of the beat is
when I start walking
and often I start conducting as well.
Yes.
Magazine that walking down the street
I'd be like James [inaudible] usual 12 year old,
oops.
And he knows it.
Oh,
what happens when Jay gets bored?
when he gets bored,
he gets killed.
The cat starts improvising.
Last week,
um,
uh,
he took the Beethoven Sonata,
the working right and now and decided that everything would be kind of
interesting,
upside down and backwards.
So he took the volume and literally did just that.
He can do it for you right now.
And um,
I couldn't even follow,
but he actually took the clefs and inverted them.
The trouble became base base.
We can trouble and did it backwards
saying she goes,
tell us a little bit the toasters,
Mike.
Right.
Five or six symphonies in a lifetime.
Jay's written five at the age of 12.
Hello,
nice to meet you
here.
Jay's explaining the storm.
Two conductor,
young hope Hawk at the rehearsal is cool.
What a strange thing to be fucking awesome at music that's kind of like
outdated,
but he got lucky man.
He got born into a great family so you can get that dude,
they should call out to him and get that dude to make some jam and pop tunes the
listen dude,
is it dead fucking song?
Nobody listens to the cello anymore,
bro.
Come on man.
You wanna make some money.
You want to be a rockstar?
You want to live like Nickelback.
They should at least get them a Mac book pro.
That's it.
Yeah,
it's the shit is crashing.
Man's got that wack ass old laptop.
He'll still running on Mac.
Yeah.
That's a shit computer.
If it can't even run a composing program will say it's like pushing a button on
the keyboard.
It's a god damn genius.
Fess up coming up with the [inaudible].
But if that kid had been born in the wrong family,
yeah,
he's dry drawing notes.
Quit drawing that shit.
What is that gate light gay language.
You get this fucking kid outta here.
What do you think is going on with that?
Do you think that's like a Asperger's and autism thing?
Is that it seems like it a little bit incarnation,
I think does weird markings on his head and he looks like you.
A shot right above the eyebrow.
Really?
Yeah.
Do you think that that happens when a baby's born,
it's been reincarnated.
You see like the wounds and people did,
did they really?
Yeah.
I wish I have a mark right on the back of my neck like I was executed.
Whoa state by those damn chairman.
You have any marks,
Joe?
Mark of the beast.
I know that.
But do you have any ink reincarnation Martin?
Yes.
It's not.
It's ugly ass hole dug and I think we've got to end this because a,
you've got to get out of here.
Fucking sucks.
I don't want to leave.
I got to go.
Well we got to go.
What are you doing?
That's more important than us going to dinner with my girlfriend.
Oh snap.
Yeah,
the one fucking day.
There was no all garden reference.
This content.
How many?
Seriously?
How many podcasts do you think you've said all of gardening and I know you get
so mad.
I know they do,
but um,
when you think about it,
like over the year or two years,
almost two years we've been doing this podcast.
When did you start doing it?
I've always just said of Guardian in normal conversation for some reason.
Yeah,
I know you have.
But in the podcast you want somewhere along the line you made a point of saying
it all the time.
I think it was just recent tit and I actually made it a point before I was just
like,
anytime I wanted to use a generic restaurant name,
I would say olive garden,
no one.
Uh,
no,
we'll,
we'll keep a joke going longer than this flux.
Great.
He is the BA phase,
the phase w Brian and I went on the road for fucking years doing clubs.
Okay.
And Brian would make these cool videos of the clubs and everything and one of
the things he would do is every time I took a picture with fans,
every time Brian would get in the background and let go.
Yeah.
I know.
I mean there's thousands of pictures and my favorites when I find it on like a
website,
there's girls with corpses and seeing that website,
but then you're just looking through it and it's like,
oh look,
Joe Rogan,
he seen me in the background making a face.
Yeah.
Dude,
I bought,
faced a picture of,
uh,
Eddie Bravo and David Lee Roth
is taking a picture of David Lee Roth and I'm in the background.
That's the buffets.
You,
it easily did that 10,000 times.
That's not an exaggeration.
Yeah,
that sounds ridiculous.
New ones all the time.
Yeah.
They're out there.
The days of my space there were easy to find and he'd go to people's,
I sometimes I saw them in people's avatars.
Yeah.
Guide it to making those cases as hemp bags on his website.
He has,
yeah,
he has.
He on your website in the office,
those bags or Megan has company mission.
10 bags are great.
What does it,
what does the website,
the website,
but s gear.com,
I think.
Something like that.
I think that's it.
You notice them on Twitter,
right?
Twitter,
DSG gear.
That's all.
All hemp,
uh,
bags and he's a Jujitsu student.
Yeah.
It's really cool.
Anyway,
um,
tonight is sold out.
Sorry.
Tomorrow night sold out to the ice house was sold out and next week San Jose,
that sold out too.
Sorry
bitches.
But I'm going to be
November 18th.
I'm going to be at clubbed verde with Neil Hamburger,
Tim Heidecker,
um,
mark proach and Natasha Leggero and that's in San Francisco in San Francisco
called again,
it's clubbed verde.
You can go to Verde club.net and that's,
it's going to be a good show.
That's a great show.
San Francisco's awesome.
One of the fucking best place,
even though I'm going to be in San Jose next week,
you know,
not San Francisco still.
I'm psyched.
Northern California's awesome.
She's still more Asians there than any place else.
There is real weird.
San Francisco's real strange.
It's weird how many Asians or are there was.
We went to San Francisco Museum once and they kind of explained it all.
Oh really?
Yeah.
It's like this weird lady is bread.
No,
no,
that's not where.
Hell good.
He's bread.
Jesus Christ.
He can't help it.
He can't help but look at them.
How can you be mad at him and you,
you know,
and you're not mad at a dog.
Um,
so,
um,
we will see you guys,
uh,
tonight at the Ice House and we're going to come back.
We're going to do another podcast with everybody that's here tonight,
including Joey Diaz.
And
is al coming on.
Al Magical out might stop by.
But Felicia,
Michael's,
Joey Diaz,
Christina presents.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
So it should be a lot of fun.
And we're set up for what?
Five microphones here for
five,
four.
And there's six that Joey Diaz couch over there
where this is,
this place is set up.
This new studio is the fucking bomb.
Diggity so we're going to do a lot of these here.
Um,
and uh,
and that's it.
My friends.
Um,
thank you very much to the flashlight.
And if you go to Joe rogan.net,
click on the link,
enter in the code name Rogan,
you will get 15% off number one,
search term or Furman.
And Cheryl's lamb,
thank you to [inaudible] dot com o n n I t,
makers of Alpha brain knew mood,
knew mood is a five HTP supplements.
Uh,
it's five HTP and a bunch of other stuff including El Tryptofan,
which,
uh,
believe converts to five HTP,
which eventually converged to serotonin.
And the idea is that it's a like a time release sort of effect.
Uh,
I've been a digging that too.
I've been trying that.
I like five HTP something a Neil Brennan told me about.
You ever try out?
Um,
yeah,
I did.
I took it one day.
I can still feel good.
Yeah,
it's nice.
It makes you feel good.
Like you feel,
I feel kind of
Nice know it makes you feel like,
you know,
like you said,
it actually makes them like more
Sam e it's in this stuff called Sam [inaudible].
Right.
I think that's where I took it anyway.
Whatever.
Anyway,
Alpha brain,
uh,
if you go to,
um,
uh,
Joe rogan.net and click on the link for Alpha brain entering the code name Rogan
and you will get 10% off dot.
And,
uh,
try that new MOOC at as well.
And um,
that is it.
Ladies and gentlemen,
we will be back next week.
We got a bunch of different crazy mother fuckers coming in next week.
Um,
uh,
no one's tied down yet,
but there's some interesting ones really interesting once.
So,
um,
that's it.
And Joey Diaz and Eddie Bravo and I are talking about doing regular MMA podcasts
and might as well do.
I'm here because there's more room and Joey can scream and shout.
But the idea is people keep saying like,
wow,
you guys talk about MMA,
why don't you talk about it?
Because a lot of times it's just me talking,
you know?
It's like,
you know,
if it's with you guys,
I'm talking to MMA with you guys.
I mean Dunkin,
you saw the fights in England,
but it,
you know,
I mean,
how much do you want to talk about it?
Oh,
that one got kicked out.
One guy.
That was awesome.
I wouldn't mind talking about some of the musical choices people come on with
another podcast.
Yeah,
there's a cool video of Chris Liebing coming out to that mad mad world song.
Yeah.
And the audience is singing along to it.
It's really cool,
man.
And I didn't realize it was happening while I was doing the commentary because
we're talking and the music's playing really loud.
We can't see it.
But this video is pretty dope.
It's like Chris bins coming out,
you know,
faces laces
and everyone's singing along to it and it's really kinda chilling,
you know,
it's really kind of catchy.
Anyway,
thank you everybody for everything you do.
Thanks for being a part of this.
Without you guys,
we wouldn't be doing this.
Um,
thank you for all the cool Twitter messages,
all the cool message,
board posts,
everything we,
uh,
as much as this serves you guys,
it serves us as well.
This is the most fun shit we get to do.
And,
uh,
the fact that you guys all dig it makes it much,
much better.
We appreciate the fuck out of it and we're committed to keeping this podcast
free.
So a free to you always.
Thank you very much for everybody and uh,
we'll see you soon.
Bye.
And we know you love him.
We love you.
Okay.
Yeah.